two hello hello it is
your friendly neighborhood podcasters
Ethan Clyde of the H3 podcast joined by
my beautiful swaggy wife Ela he's been
swagged out
so hard lately it just doesn't stop
thank you it's not gonna okay
[Music]
yeah yeah
also I want to say happy trans
visibility day today
we see you and we're coming for you to
give you hugs oh I'm coming if anything
I'm coming at to your defense as always
you are valid you are worthy we love you
and shame on everybody who's gonna be on
the wrong side of History they're gonna
have to come at us first and guess what
it's all online all these all these
pieces of crap who are putting out all
this transphobic stuff it's all on video
bro it's like if you go back to like uh
I don't know if you go back to like you
know Jim Crow everyone was popping off
with all this crazy rays of stuff it
wasn't on video on YouTube now it is
internet's forever [__] internet's
forever [__] ass 50 years you're gonna
have to answer your grandkids they're
gonna spit on your grave bro cause
you're such a scumbag
yeah that's what we're doing here today
so
um you said it bid on your granny a
grave man
yes so uh oh thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring this episode we love you so
much
okay we've got a lot to get to lots of
fun stuff here today first of all look
how
this shirt which is so cool
turn around
what are we doing here we do it oh
my God
it's gone Angela
well we're actually going Angela Angela
Angela basket that's the thing we're
going to do a little Runway over there
we're gonna do a Runway should we do it
now already yeah over here we're doing
it this coming week on Thursday Petty
fresh Godzilla collaboration is coming
out to Great Fanfare this collection is
amazing Godzilla is beloved by all and
so here we're gonna pop up some pieces
as the crew graciously models oh my God
who is she who is she we may never know
this is our bikes Jersey top and Sam I
believe made her own skirt so go off
okay I was gonna pop dude your outfit is
popping off you made that skirt yeah
Sam looks amazing thank you girl work it
that's the biker uh bike Jersey Mike
Jersey okay whoa whoa there is Olivia
Olivia uh this is the I guess you know
more than Mila well it's a button up and
then she's got our skirt underneath
which is a really cool wrap skirt and
it's got the little webbing belt
yep so this is not a Godzilla item it's
just a core item coming out on Thursday
in the same collection to complement the
Godzilla thank you Queen
okay Zach you know he swag it out with
the camp shirt how does it feel Zach
tell me about it
he says he feels different we were
really inspired by the Vintage Godzilla
the old stuff and so this poster is like
one of my all-time favorites may I ask
how come there's like a double on the
head that's because he unbuttoned it
you oh Zach had to go so deep with the
button there's there it is so button
down at your own uh wrist your own wrist
yeah
you got to pay for that I'm sick yeah
right here we got the mesh top
uh we we commissioned uh one of my
favorite artists to work with she does
this Great hand-drawn uh drawings so we
had her make her own hand-drawn Godzilla
and then all these like cool elements of
like destruction
helicopters building on Fires yeah
and Lena is working it looking fabulous
thank you girly
slay City cam uh these colors as he was
saying and I agree it just brings out
the inner cam doesn't it yes it really
does I love
um he's up in a mug that matches the
whole color palette I love how you
styled it with a yellow shirt under it's
awesome
um so we went here pretty uh simple with
the design but it's got like this
destruction element so we made it kind
of like distressed okay A little
distressed and just really fun colors
because that's what we're about that's
it thank you Cameron awesome amazing you
worked it so okay AV got the glasses on
where's he's at and this is a real
[__] cool streetwear yeah right here
boy yeah that's the the crew neck for
the streetwear kind of guy you know he
doesn't want to wear too much color pop
it out Dan you like the new trolls he
likes the black look how cool he is the
one color print because he's
sophisticated
you've been working out he says yes
looks like it
all right and then uh Dan is this is
damn coming on in here with the
now this is this one yeah we we were so
inspired by the character of Godzilla
and the like this like Ray that comes
out of his mouth so we went with a buff
print for him and then embroidery for
the blue details to kind of like
exaggerate it keep hold that hold that
wait damn space hold it hold it and we
did hold it dance race
it doesn't listen to me he doesn't
follow my instructions Dan's always been
his own man
I don't know oh it's my turn oh wait
hold on then go back just the I want to
point out the um embroidery yeah that
kind of
it's got a little bit of like a glittery
yeah it's got a glittery element it
looks so cool yeah looks so he looks so
cool all right I'm gonna pop in there
he's so cool
he's so cool he's so cool
all right
Here Comes our Muse Ethan Klein
um Ethan likes a really bold outfit and
so this is the kind of shirt that is
specifically designed for Ethan it's it
go it goes all out there's no holding
back love it it's just all out there one
thousand percent all the time talk to me
baby
fires
and his dance moves out on fire
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah
love that love that
zip up Hoodie can you zip it up Ela
it's so nice
dude I love that graphic and the
the zip up hoodie it's beautiful it's
perfect I'm loving it
well okay they didn't see those wait
they didn't see him no show us the shoes
one more time
what the hell
please stomp on my balls with those
that's all I ask Here Comes Ian with my
favorite piece Ian looks so cool Ian is
the street where God he is working it
he's loving it this is like our pixel
Godzilla interpretation yeah
yes our statement sweater of this
collection I would say
um he's floating he's in the artwork and
executing it in the Jacquard within the
sweater is my favorite thing to do when
we work with collaborations right we
don't do it the simple way we try to
really make a design and then okay he's
feeling natural he looks like a natural
up there but you know he should go back
there one second yeah this it's just the
sweater came out so nice the pattern
it's so unique and again with the with
the embroidery the glittery embroidery
uh nuclear laser moment we're loving it
thank you Ian thank you thank you I
appreciate that thank you
is that everybody
and there's is that everything or is
there there's more items too I'd imagine
I think there's a couple more t-shirts
there's like oh there's a tie
and then there's a flame Style
so those are coming out on Thursday of
next week so thank you everybody looking
absolutely
fantastic thank you guys so much on this
one giant godzilla fan here cool I'm
glad yeah it came out so you know I got
to say I think AV is running with the
missing items Oh either oh hey one sec
there gabo gabo
yes so oh we got the couple more items
oh my God I'm just all over the plate
man I'm all over the place all right
take your time
I can't talk I'm
I'm just I'm just I'm just all over the
place with my day Matt my day right now
I don't feel like talking right now oh
my God what's going on are you okay
she's distressed uh I'm just I'm just
trying to stop baby what's going on oh
my God
what's wrong it's not my day I'm just
I'm just all over the place wow all over
the place
what does it mean that you're all over
did you hang up what
are you okay
you hung up wait is he okay wait he's
never hung up Zach was that a bit you
guys he's okay yeah he's okay but I
don't I didn't get the joke
well it's a little different pace we
were trying we were trying something
different well I guess it didn't go off
great I
I what was the strategy with that well
every week we you know I'll ask the
inner AB whoever like what can we do
with Gabe and then I think a b
throughout the idea like let's let's
have him just like be all frantic and
hang up the call
which I'm like
oh it's different I couldn't leave them
like that though I couldn't be like all
right well Gabe everybody on to the rest
of the show okay well Gabe
he's doing well we're I'm happy to hear
that
the there's this other skirt actually I
love this shirt too my favorite as well
because it's again taking those elements
that were on the mesh mesh top so we did
it also as a T-shirt and it's on the tie
all this really cute drawings of um
destruction is what I like to do
destruction
of uh just flames
awesome thank you guys thank you guys so
much for participating
very exciting this one where we're happy
we're excited about it this year is
looking pretty good for Teddy fresh I
gotta say there's um there's a huge
collab coming up
is it
is it the month after next thank you um
it's um
two months two months after this one
it's like the biggest IP you can imagine
but for me this year resembles a lot
because the previous year
was like a lot of the collections that
were coming out were things that were
being worked on when I felt like the
company internally was not in a good
place and right last year was really
hard for me but
made it through and really I feel like
such a better place this year internally
within the company so everything that's
coming out now is also for me a
representation of like the new times of
things being better internally and
externally yeah I'm proud of you you
worked through it man not easy you know
really worked through it we've been
through so much over there with Teddy
fresh yeah building a business from the
from you know ground up really literally
it's been a it's been a crazy Journey
of uh got it so I'm probably pushing six
years now almost there that's crazy it's
crazy it'll be six years in October yeah
damn that's nuts
well there you go ELO you are you are
coming into it man so good for you proud
of you thank you
somehow you get more beautiful every
year you have Kit you have more kids and
you become more beautiful into a paradox
no it's not a paradox it's just um
all women stay beautiful forever there's
never an age I mean
what can I say just ages age is just a
number it's a journey that will be for
over years for me to discover myself and
so
can you believe that R Kelly put out a
song to National Fame worldwide Fame and
adoration or was it R Kelly or Aaliyah
age is just a number it's the two of
them no they put out a song age is just
a number
what the [__] dude the world was crazy
not that long ago yeah but we can't talk
about Queen Aaliyah she's a queen no of
course I'm talking about bro I'm never I
would never throw dirt on her name
yeah so anyway moving on here a little
bit also kind of related I'll touch on
it real fast congratulations you've got
a little write-up there for ELO's Street
where
collabo oh we have a skate deck coming
everyone loved that last time yeah here
it is a little preview
yeah it's sick Sam made the set we're
gonna be dropping these photos soon Sam
won an amazing job
I saw her paper macheing those little
limbos on there boy
[Applause]
nope and it looked like you were gonna
say something
I was gonna they're Scrabble pieces but
I was like wait that why I don't that's
not important but I just thought it was
cool yeah the little uh the lights in
the it was cool wait tiles our Scrabble
piece is made of paper they're like I
got no it's wood Villa wood it would Oh
I thought that'd be too heavy oh no I
didn't know that not too heavy for a
glue dot i there it is Scrabble pieces
gotta work with what you've got you know
up Roxy uh check it out you know if you
want to read about it appreciate them
right live at the uproxy
there's no y at the end yeah up Rock oh
up Rock night at the rock up Roxy May
13th there it is oh okay we do love up
rocks I think somebody there is a family
of the show I have a feeling
what would this be life from his culture
they've always been super nice to us and
I love them yeah well I don't see it on
their own page so
how much do they love us I'm just
kidding
it just went up so uh anyway thank you
to them
thank you to Elena two seven nine for
five gifted subs thank you thank you so
much
also God it just never stops uh the ELA
hype train has not yet slowed down
another look crushing out on Instagram
thank you here we go Whitney Cummings
invited me to the premiere of the roast
of Bert Kreischer
I was also there at the live event who
is she
a damn boy well you were there for the
recording of the Iowa yeah oh that must
have been super fun I am scared to find
out the footage because they said they
have like a 360 camera it was in the
middle of the crowd and I was I was
right next to it oh [__] oh no your boss
did
yeah it also just looks really wild when
you're close to one of those two cameras
this was the premiere
I saw his wife and daughters which was
cool because I've always heard about
them and especially yeah he always
talked about how dumb his daughters are
they look great and not dumb
um and I saw oh Bryce Hall was there the
same day that you had him on the show
isn't that weird it's just so weird I
saw him and I was like hey you were just
on the podcast yeah and then the other
guy that's a tick tock guy that I didn't
know his name oh yeah oh yeah you guys
took a photo together Josh Richards yes
who uh is he's a pseudo enemy of the
show I would say not remind me he's the
guy who hosted with Dave porkwood
then
oh he's a picture too pseudo enemy
nothing that can't be squashed yeah beef
is or Bryce is a friend of the show
and I met some okay so he's only an
enemy by proxy yeah it's not his fault
it's not his fault he was saying he's a
victim it was just there he's like the
Iraqi villager you know Saddam Hussein's
fault it's not your fault thank you but
I will bomb you if I need to come over
there I met k it Katie who was a
bachelorette
Aldo girl you remember that damn loves
her oh
how could I ever forget I didn't know
she's becoming a stand-up
comedian yeah she has kind of a new
Venture into comedy oh she ended up with
the guy I didn't like wait are they
still together
this is them the guy Donkey Kong Country
oh Donkey Kong no no I do remember that
wait is Taylor still here Taylor are you
here
she's here
is she together with the guy is she
together with Donkey Kong Country
somebody else
the same place yes is she there next to
Lena yeah Taylor is uh
uh and Taylor has stepped into the role
of managing Eva
so Taylor's the one who's been doing my
makeup
ever since uh you guys noticed like the
post-looking fire
it wasn't me it was Taylor
and then um I really like working with
her and so she's becoming like we're
trying to figure out what's the title
because I thought it's manager and um
apparently people are confused by that
title I thought I just managed okay
whatever listening you know what I mean
no but here's Donkey Kong Country uh you
say you met her
excellent
and then
I am at Adrian who
who all-time housewife from Beverly
Hills oh that's that that was the
highlight of your night wasn't it this
is the guy and listen
apparently she knew who I was no and she
listens to the podcast I don't believe
it that's what I said I said I don't
believe it
I'm gonna pull up a picture of her
because she's like um I don't want to be
wait is this her is there more than one
Adrian Adrian
um what's her last name oh this is her
this is her
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so she's an old she's a housewife
uh Beverly Hills Legacy and she says she
watches the I don't think she does I
think I just don't think she's already
she knew my name she knew your name she
was waiting to meet you yes okay Adrian
maybe she could be watching does she
have daughters perhaps that are in
Arizona I do think she's got kids
yeah this guy did he cheat on her or
something
there do I need a dog for her I think
she was there with somebody else oh
massive
he's on that bot show yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's The Botch guy yeah Paul uh
Paul right Paul hold on I need to see if
he cheated on her I'm gonna dog him if
he did hold on wait their last name's
Maloof right yes yeah yeah they they are
blue yeah they own like the Palms hotel
or something yes no they're rich as [__]
yeah crazy Rich massive aloof when she
was on the show everybody was talking
about her like she was one of the
richest uh Housewives you know okay for
like vendor pump let me get the details
on their divorce so I have no if I can
eat a dog him or not because girl I got
your back now uh Adriana Malu inside her
nasty divorce okay okay okay
I can see what's going on here [__]
uh uh uh uh Paul if that is your real
name the uh rhinoplasty specialist oh
yeah that dude okay I'm not even gonna
go there
let's see
um storybook wedding dueling court
papers gun allegations oh Lord
Nassif has turned in his guns okay this
is pretty messy holy [__]
can you tell me if he cheated or not
maybe I don't want to read this whole
article
I'm looking
the ass chat gbt please if uh chat EBT
will know
gp's up
you know what you guys always make fun
of me for using chat GPT this is the
funniest and best application let's ask
it to fact check gossip and I don't care
what anyone says this [__] is funny I'm
gonna [__] fact that gossip and
cutting as gpt4
okay and you guys are all gonna sit here
and watch it what's his name again
Paul massive
wait I thought it was aloof no no her
last name's Maloof Adrian's Maloof oh
okay it's just nastiff like this
n-a-s-i-f-n-a-s-s-i-f I believe SS no
okay so did Paul Nassif
the plastic surgeon
surgeon
cheat on his wife all right you [__]
tell me what's up AI robot [__] I know
you can't do that be coming at you there
was no verified reports of him uh
cheating
um was it was this a race one he says of
September 2021
it had to have been after that then oh
[__] I'm telling you you gotta update
your yeah behind the curve it doesn't
know there's no popcorn if you if you
ask it if if uh Adrian malouf's husband
cheated on her it says yes if you ask it
that way are you serious wait so why
didn't what is this propaganda I'm gonna
try that
[Laughter]
so okay so did
did Adrian aloof's husband
did Adrian malouf's husband
cheat on her
uh I'll I'll even qualify it
was Adrian relief
of the Beverly housewives
Joe
Adrian Malouf who appeared on the Real
Housewives was married to Paul Nassif
okay there were numerous uh rumors and
speculation about the relationship
including infidelity however it's
important to note that rumors shut up
gossip
I mean this is how I sent it maybe I
should have clarified the name of the
ex-husband
did you use The Cutting Edge chat gpt4
to uh three point three points there's
your problem
right here it doesn't have the uh
computing power too anyway okay we love
you we stand you and we hate your
ex-husband evil evil evil man
I hate him
well that's fun lot going on for you and
I'm proud of you so God bless man you
got a tick tock uh getting ready
yeah I'm trying to get into Tick Tock
hopefully they don't ban it right when I
start to get into it well Elish oh yeah
they will don't worry
Elena was also saying that Lena's I
guess popping off on uh Tick Tock and
it's not easy
you know you put all this effort in and
then
I'm so excited that ELO's like gonna be
on Tick Tock more and people are just
love to see like the behind the scenes
of the of everything so thank you I'm so
excited for it if somebody can get me
verified I think it would help
here you are with Bert who by the way is
this this idea and again I'm not one to
criticize anyone but other than don't
well Bert he's easy to make fun of I
mean that's like his whole nature just
walking around being clowned on for
being fat and gross and he put on a nice
jacket he looks hype as [__] the Jordans
on okay all right okay I mean I don't
know and shut up with his wife and
daughters you know doing it right Bert
also has an amazing watch collection so
that's just kind of the cherry on top
maybe I'm just a hat like that kind of
hat just doesn't again I'm not the
fashion police but I kind of am at the
same time is that what's happening yeah
a little bit of fun I tell you I was at
home with both every single person that
saw me what's the first question
is Ethan here well that's fair we're
always together sure you know they'd ask
me the same thing but I was at home with
both the kids yes all night you know
moving pieces
you came home they're both asleep Alpha
Behavior a good dad okay
I get what you're trying to say with
that sound but at the same time
knowing yeah I don't like it
um
here's something that's interesting
I had
previously swear that I heard AB say
about the movie Black Adam he said Big
Black Adam
and I said did one of y'all say big
black Adam and then you're both like no
nobody said that and you and I felt like
a weirdo like big black Adam but what's
interesting about Big Black Adam
um is that well you did kind of say it
kind of together at the same time check
this out
to absolve me
it's muted okay I don't hear anything
okay all right okay I think this is
muted still uh-huh unmute thank you so
much to Oblivion
yeah dude see
I don't hear [__]
I am black no y'all thought I was crazy
for that one but I I goddamn heard it
Big Black Adam
shame on you both yeah so we explain it
it was I mean Dan Bull talking at the
same time I'm gonna watch it again okay
let's talk about that black Adams thing
we got like sidetracked into Oblivion
I said big time because I was referring
to how much we got sidetracked I said
big time and then he simultaneously was
correcting you for seeing Black Adams
which we said like 10 times at that
point that's so funny Black Adam you
gotta pull that deck
you got it
oh I said I'll pull it uh I don't know
black and I'm not black Adams plural did
he not say that
ah that was awesome that was awesome
thank you for pointing that out uh
people in the at Arena we love that
about you love it I'm gonna bring like a
chalkboard and write down what I want to
say and just hold it up from now on
we'll just criticize your handwriting
true
um
uh no we could never uh Bryce basically
okay so we had Bryce on on yeah
Wednesday right which was
I expected it to be good it was a great
episode you know he he turned out to be
a great guest
and I feel that we bonded you guys feel
that we bonded yeah oh yeah I feel that
you opened up he opened up I got a lot
of respect for people that grow up in
that kind of way you know because yeah
he's so easy to make all these
assumptions about people and I think a
lot of people would even assume that
Bryce was like rich just rich white kid
whatever but he really um and like I
would have never assumed that he was
bullied I feel like he's it was probably
like the cool kid in school that's what
I thought apparently he lost a bunch of
weight
I was bullied he was bullied for his red
hair
and uh you know I I really think his dad
abandoned him when he was two years old
yeah that's I think the worst it's right
up there with one of the worst things a
person can do period Point Blank so you
know I'm with him that being said there
was a great moment when Brad the bull
and at one point even Ryan kavkav called
him and uh so he was he was building up
like yo Brad wants to say what up to you
I was like really and so then he calls
Brad up he puts him on on video call and
points him to me without get it
preparing him
and I noted I was like oh my God he
looks pissed he looks so annoyed and um
somebody isolated
and stabilized the phone so you can see
what I saw and it's and it is great so
here he is he sees me and he's like hell
no dude I mean it's so good
that's what I saw nobody else saw it
somebody in the comments of that thread
suggested it'd be a button screen and
it's definitely going to be yeah
I'm trying to figure out what he's
saying
he's saying like dude dang yeah it's
like just like dude he can't believe me
some kind of exclamation like dude what
the [__]
is it I mean have you ever seen a more
disappointed expression
he's like hell no dude even with the
glasses you can see behind us
such a stud though isn't he
so hot such a stud God he's good looking
I know oh I would leave him sorry Eula I
would leave you no I wouldn't
the ball
yeah and then here's the moment that I
guess everybody really enjoyed right
after that uh okay
actually can you time stamp the whole
uh because I really like that whole
interaction because he goes get off the
topic please yeah I said we're moving on
Brad
he goes I hate that topic
yeah here it's really holy [__] kids
that dude has been busy yeah and he and
they all start with BR really all the
kids start with VR yeah somebody I said
who's else's name how many Briar names
and then everyone's like uh your son
birth Ethan has a whole son named Bruce
I said Fair Point that is fair but when
I was watching it my head also didn't
even click really yeah I have to admit
it's just not a common name these days
Bruce so it didn't strike me but there's
a lot of BR names Brooks Bruce Brian
Brett
Brian Bradley Bradley
Brianna
Brianna yeah
what are what are their BR names are
there Brian there's like Brandon wait is
this story spot
operated
Brody
um no where's the where's the um Brandon
time stamp of When Brad calls in
Brooklyn I'm looking for him yeah thank
you Dan I'm moved on
Brenda thanks
Brantley oh Brantley don't forget
thank you guys now I moved on past that
already thank you though
Braylon
raylen that's not a man
[Applause]
Brinley Brinley I ain't never met no
problem
some really weird ones Brantley
the name of my high school a music
teacher brently Brinley or last name I
can't emphasize how deep lore this is
yeah we're live right now Brad the bull
the legend God damn it I can't stallion
all right hold on hold on Bruno
guys we moved on we moved on
Brogan Rogan that's not a name stop
Brittany did we say Brittany we didn't
say Brittany
bro bro
okay here we go
I'll I'll call Brad real bad this is
great because I can't okay [__]
YouTube goddamn thing with the in a long
podcast it just doesn't work
playing uh right now that's 10 seconds
okay here we go okay
I'll I'll call Brad real bad this is
great because I can't emphasize how deep
lore this is yeah we're live right now
okay so Bryce is such a legend he gets
them on video call and he puts them
right over yeah
he has no idea what's going on and
apparently Brad and kav Kev are like
best friends
which is interesting by the way Bryce
and Bryce is really friendly with them
no they're his besties Bryce doesn't
give a [__] he's like he's CR he's cool
as hell like that he's super honest too
I like him he's got good he's got good
traits I like him but um one I think I
did learn from him was that
Brad yeah asked kavcav they were best
friends before
and then according to Bryce
I question this narrative he says kav
Kev no Brad asked kafkaf can I date your
ex wife and their best friends bro code
first of all that's [__] crazy second
of all there ain't no way peace and love
okay that they weren't already [__]
wow bro you could really gonna ask your
best friend if you can [__] if you
can date his ex-wife I mean that's wild
[__] I mean at least he asked right okay
fine I mean am I am I alone on that
that's crazy I mean yeah it's crazy and
I I mean it is a crazy scenario the the
the timeline seemed like they were still
in the process of getting divorced so
like they weren't even like fully set
like I could see it five years very soon
times have changed your best friend
your best friend let's just say
hypothetically you and Ali break up your
best friend comes and says hey I've got
a I've had a thing for her yeah like can
I ask her out the next day and she says
yes is that Gonna Make You Feel yeah you
know obviously it's [__] up like
friendship over yeah right yeah but then
you start to wonder how long has this
been going on right they've been
interested in each other especially
since again it just seemed like it
happened
as they were breaking up this divorce is
fresh yeah and by the way let's not
forget that we've seen photos of them
all in bed together
I did actually forget about that yeah no
I didn't Ryan is submissive
you know yeah that's what I assume yeah
so you know assumption nothing's
definite but that's his that's his
shtick man he digs that you know please
Brad come [__] my wife and then [__] me
yeah I mean maybe he likes maybe I look
I'm just speculating here I don't know
well why else would the all three of
them be in a bed together crazy well
Brian might it's not crazy it's a good
ass time he might be clean up you know
you never know
here what is this one it says Jess and
my third ex-husband though you did not
call him that
Jess and my third ex-husband ex-wife
chess that's his ex
that's Brad the bull
on Valentine's Day they all got together
he says Jess
right is that Jess
no the woman the hoodie okay so that's
his ex-wife yeah and my third ex husband
ex-wife slash ex-wife just want to point
something out it looks like Brad has his
arm around two of them I think I think
Ryan is there for cleanup and a watch
and to jerk off in the corner again I
speculate and that's not a problem
that's not a problem not at all I'm not
King shaming but that's his that's what
he likes listen here here's what I'll
admit I'm guilty to I am personally very
interested from a guy I I'm a I'm
interested in the public figure Ryan
Cavanaugh and I gossip and I quit and I
just speculate about his personal life
it's it's it's fun and he's just he you
know it's like a mega celebrity and I
want to know what's going on in their
bedroom it's none of my business I know
but
good
is Brad the bull Israeli okay
he says he's American but he's Jewish
okay yeah because he looks just like
your [__] brother like on steroids
it's crazy dude
yeah
there's a lot of differences though but
Brad is a very unisraeli name hold on we
asked chat well is this chat gbt4. get
caught by his wife as an AI language
model I cannot provide real-time
information on Gossip it's important to
respect people's privacy and void
spreading rumors or false information
shut up you dumbass robot you're a robot
idiot you don't know anything shut up
stupid ass [__] robot [__] you
[__] yes I apologize yeah [__] go
go apologize to someone who cares [__]
stupid ass robot I'm canceling my
[__] membership I'm not here to get
I'm not here to get ethical uh lessons
from a goddamn right yeah computer chip
all right um we have got to go to our
ads and then we have a guest calling in
very soon we wanted to set them up
before they called in so we should uh
get the ad done and so um I didn't let
me just blast through this real fast
sure yeah here it is a bowl the legend
so that's that's when he looks super
disappointed the play-by-play here
and then Bryce is like oh I [__] up he
looked pissed didn't know they were they
keep playing the the bull sound and I'm
like this guy's gonna get an ego
but now we do we uh we we talked about
it it was very very short
um I just got a understanding of the
beef and now we're done yeah we're
moving on Brad
okay he said much he's saying you know
on Tick Tock uh love posted the clip and
he turned it up a lot but he what he
says is please do I don't like the topic
or something like that right okay yeah
yeah okay and I said that's fair enough
fair enough thanks Brad
hey Brad
thanks for taking care of her bro how do
you do that stop the smell like that bye
I'm complimenting him he's the bull man
so that everybody loved that and uh well
Ryan Kavanaugh
so
Ryan Cavanaugh
yeah
did Bryce make it seem like Ryan Kevin
uh was interested in talking to you
because he kind of brought that upside
but I don't think there's interest on
either side frankly yeah to communicate
yeah I don't think it'd be productive
it'd be like the last episode of
Frenemies you know it's like irregular
here here
irreputable you're you're reconciliable
differences
oh my God
oh burrito before it shows so don't feel
bad
fool
already putting it out there because I
know I don't think our sponsor
and then we have a really interesting
call
from this
psychopath floor at Florida man who
wanders the Everglades at night Barefoot
harassing wild deadly Wildlife love
maybe harassing isn't a good term yeah I
don't think he's harassing well because
we've learned some more about him and he
he definitely knows
he's a good dude he's a good dude I
don't mean to imply I'm just it's almost
like he's flirting with that I say that
because I have that thought as well but
now that we've learned more about him
it's actually pretty cool what he does
he's flirting with death
though he's Fearless so thank you to our
wonderful sponsor today Shopify
love them Shopify
we built our entire Teddy fresh business
from day one on Shopify day one and
and think about
places no regrets in fact there's one I
think it's the best decision we ever
made I think so and I always recommend
it to everybody yeah so if you ever want
to make a website or specifically an
e-commerce website
Shopify is the one place
to do it honestly
um that's a sale of another a sound of
another sale on Shopify
yeah so it's a Commerce platform that
revolutionized businesses around the
world you know if you're selling
anything from clothing to freaking
chocolate bars
Shopify simplifies selling online in
person so you can focus on successfully
growing your business
um
it's crazy they have everything they've
got like the processor they've got like
uh the themes to set up a website it's
so easy yes to be up and running and
accepting payments that's the most
intuitive
lesson you know yeah intuitive intuitive
you don't need to know much ahead of the
ahead of it you if you can manage to
start without knowing anything and learn
as you go I mean we made it with like us
and one person yeah easy Shopify covers
every sales channel from in-person POS
system to an all-in-one e-commerce
platform it even lets you sell across
social media marketplaces like Tick Tock
Facebook Instagram it plugs into
everything
it's a pack packed with industry-leading
tools ready to ignite your growth
Shopify gives you complete control of
your business and your brand
without having to learn any new skills
or design and code the one thing I
really like is they have an app
uh Marketplace and people spend so much
time they're building up these
incredible apps and services and add-ons
yes that are invaluable and you just
click of the button you add them a lot
of them are like Services you can get in
touch with people there's so much yes
for example if you're in the business of
clothing
there's an app for returns that makes
the return process super easy orders an
app for back in stock if you want people
to sign up for when something is back in
stock and it notifies them and notifies
you how many people are waiting right
that's another good one and less crazy a
high and uh like analytics apps and I
think like I said these apps are all
like individual businesses with their
own support team and stuff too
yeah they've got 24 7 help and extensive
business courses online too
Shopify is there to support your success
every step of the way
yeah from a small business to a
still kind of a medium small business
medium feels like a big medium
yeah what's incredible is that you know
no matter how big you want to grow it
Shopify is there to empower you with the
confidence and control to revolutionize
your business I think there's there's I
think billion dollar businesses are on
Shopify I mean I'm sure they are now
it's your time to get serious about
selling and try Shopify today
this is possibility
powered by Shopify sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period that's
sweet at shopify.com after dark
all lower case go to shopify.com after
Dark
to take your business to the next level
shopify.com
after dark all lowercases one dollar a
month trial period fantastic thank you
Shopify we love you
thank you
this chicken's a little weird it's like
ground chicken I didn't expect that it
is interesting
I think it's Buzz button personally you
like the ground chicken yeah yeah this
didn't expect ground chicken I don't
think I've ever had that for Mexican
restaurants Fried Chicken [__] Fried
Chicken bro
all right
I gotta chew my food damn
is counting the seconds take your time
thank you all good
authors have a minute of dead air and
they quietly chew their food
that's what's up Zach's original this is
a remix exactly yeah very good let's go
feel an alpha
okay let's go
feeling out for today
put one foot in
pick your right foot out
now do it up
both hands in the air
villain Alpha
feeling real good
now spin around
now jump in the air
hop three times
okay let's go
bounce everybody bounce Alpha time
now lean into your partner
now lean away from your partner
alpha alpha and stop
so today we have a
the Everglades uh guy here let's see so
this guy's name is fishing Garrett fish
and Garrett
actually pretty popular tick Douglas
four million followers
um and here let me show you a couple
examples
of this guy he's gonna blow your mind
this man
goes into the wild Florida Everglades
everglaves which is swampland inhabited
by crocodiles
by snakes from Arizona
or alligators snakes spiders every
manner of dangerous scary creature you
can imagine
it's one of the more wild places in
America
and this man goes around Barefoot let's
take a look guys I'm exploring the
Florida Everglades well that kind of
startled me not gonna lie but they're
literally everywhere found where all the
swamp puppies hang out you guys see all
of those eyes well it looks like I got
myself surrounded by alligators again
it's kind of my fault though because I'm
calling them up to me
but they're all still sweethearts and I
love every one of them but you still
gotta watch your back
this bugger thinks I don't see him right
here I'm watching you buddy
you little fellow you're pretty brave to
get this close to me hey Mr cottonmouth
did you just strike at me come on we got
to get you across the road cottonmouth
is very look at this little Gekko
where's your mama extreme you don't look
too happy with me
oh you got an attitude hey I respect it
it's gonna serve you well in the long
run
yoink
a gentle yoink we got a Scarlet snake
What a Mighty impressive web you got
here Mr tropical or believer dang this
is a thick one you want to crawl on me
he's insane
at least he appears to be the meme oh my
God by himself I think too you know I
mean like if you disappear in the
Everglades nobody finds your body
you'll get eaten
I've never talks this is crazy yeah
here's another one
there's a whole bunch of them I mean
this is just what this guy does
this hey guys I'm in the Florida
Everglades balancing on this slippery
log chicken Garrett
there's an alligator right underneath me
hopefully I don't fall he doesn't know
I'm here yet juicy bullfrog yoink what
what do you have to say for yourself
mister
he is letting me hear it
right here we got a yellow rat snake
you're a great native snake that we have
here in the Everglades he gave me a
little kiss love these guys so much glad
I could get him out of the road safely
I'm on a stroll looking for that 20-foot
Burmese python
alligator kept biting into the mud I was
wondering what he's doing turns out he's
grabbing fish out of the grass really
cool to see this feeding Behavior I
ended up leaving him alone and letting
him do his thing later I hooted up these
barred owls listen
you guys don't know by now I can talk to
animals ended up giving this one a juicy
rat don't ask how I did all that but
he's happy now love you buddy you better
love me back
check out this leopard frog
love you guys how does it not move why
does it let him do that how is he not
getting hurt every day
I'm assuming he knows what he's doing I
spoke to him uh yeah sorry he he
definitely knows what he's doing he
knows what he's yeah and he uh he
actually has a really good message he
wants to save animals
uh well Zach I'm gonna talk to him
actually
oh I'm just you know I'm just leading it
up
so that'll be great for him to explain
to me
thank you these have a lot of views too
damn
um
another clip of him wandering and
finding animals let's see you know me
just walking barefoot through the
Everglades again
look at this little gecko swimming away
so cute he found cover he's all safe
this isn't the mama but I got really
close to this Gator oh my God I'm trying
to get his attention
oh he sees me I hope I don't blink this
green water snake was lighting me up I
don't know what it is she's bleeding no
I was being so gentle but he wanted the
smoke this banded water snake is
probably the most common snake to see
out here often gets confused for a
cottonmouth but they're completely
harmless now this is a cottonmouth and
check this out a little banded water
snake went right over the top of him
he's walking down on me right now those
are like super it's one of the most
deadly snakes I think in the world
like lethal
yeah I'm looking it up right now is he
not dead
by now
Florida cottonmouth
first stripe crayfish snakes I ever
found they move a lot after a big rain
here's another clip of all those bugs
Jesus look at that yellow probably
swallowed 100 in them pants
it's compelling content it's crazy [__]
I've never seen anything like it
um cottonmouth has a powerful
cytotoxic
Venom that destroys tissue and is
considered more toxic than that of the
cop Copperhead the bite symptoms include
severe pain swelling
ecchymosis and even though deaths are
rare
they can leave scars that lead to
amputation so that's probably not what
you want no I'm not great I prefer to
keep my limbs thank you
here let's just click around here when
you're walking barefoot in the floor to
Everglades you always got to watch your
step it could be a big old lizard right
next dude what are you doing
he's walking around in the swamp
Barefoot next to goddamn crocodiles
alligators I don't know the difference
alligator
they're all alligators in Florida in
Florida and what is the crocodile
version is that um
uh crocodiles I believe are mostly in
Africa okay uh I could be wrong about
maybe salt water right people are saying
about the tropics in Africa Asia oh no
they are in Americans the Americas too
and the Everglades
uh uh it looks like there's a small
population of some crocodiles in Florida
but they're mostly in Central America
they prefer Coastal brackish salt water
habitats
yes so um
the people are calling him the Florida
Man Steve Irwin I agree with that 100 is
that the one that he's like discount and
I don't even mean this as an insult he's
like white trash Steve Irwin basically
he's the guy who died uh he's like the
animal Whisperer the stingray impaled
yeah he's a legend everyone loves him
yeah
so
uh uh
Let me refresh this
when you're walking barefoot in the
floor to Everglades you always got to
watch your step it'd be a big old lizard
right next to you too follow me and
whipped around and I can see the fear in
his eyes I love you buddy he ended up
taking off like a rocket ship then later
I found this cotton is this stud look
poisonous he's on a dirt road so I'm
gonna move him so nobody runs him over
see you later chunky boy also consider
that he only has one free hand right
he's recording
he's handling these snakes with one free
hand oh my God but like also why is he
out there at night like as if it wasn't
already scary
that's the vibe yeah I think a lot of
those animals are probably nocturnal but
it's also more [__] up for sure you
know I want to tell him that
I'm sure he knows what he's doing but
he's gonna die like he's gonna die out
there well it was not he's just gonna
stop posting I mean I just want to tell
him
it's a day Gekko I love these guys so
much wow he ended up taking a dump on me
but it's all good this okay gecko
doesn't know what's coming for him
give him the old reach around didn't
even see it coming
yeah I'm not very happy with me their
bite definitely packs a punch and he got
his revenge so cool he is letting me
have it barking every second this one
was very good
guys I'm gonna be posting some bangerson
you're not going to want to miss him so
did he take those home because he looks
like he was in a car there
he's just taking home geckos
bringing home geckos bars
mommy got me some geckos tonight boy
here I'll watch one more then we'll
bring them on this one has freaking 20
million dudes hey guys don't forget your
bug spray out in the Everglades you may
get a few insects at all what as long as
you don't breathe it's not too bad oh
later that night I took a little raw dog
stroll through the Everglades I like to
get as far out there as I possibly can
I found these little hatchling geckos
this is not something you want to get
close to when you're in the middle of
the Everglades and just as I thought the
Mama's right here this could be a very
sketchy situation if you don't know what
you're doing and she is eyeballing me oh
my God she's letting the baby geckos
swim away oh they're so cute standing
right in between them she ended up bee
lining right at me sometimes I push the
limits on how close I can get but I do
know what I'm doing just like the last
Mama alligator I encountered she's just
doing her job and she needs her space
wow and this ladies and gentlemen I
guess why they call them cotton mouse
this is a defensive display telling me
to keep my distance they are so gorgeous
they will not chase you just don't be in
the way where they're trying to go hey
guys don't forget your bug spray his
videos so good
there's so many with so many views all
of them have like millions and millions
all right I'll bring them in so this is
fishing gear
that's right
stand back on the line with fish and
Garrett now hey guys check out all these
hopefully uh
uh the service won't be a problem we did
test before but he is out in the
wilderness
um he is in the Everglades yes so and uh
we tested it uh right before the show
and his connection was okay I just let
him in and it's pending
[Music]
we're Pros out there it's not as easy as
it looks all right time for some natives
this is an Eastern hognose I love these
guys I found them in Central Florida
I've been looking for one of these guys
for a while he's so chunky aren't they
adorable this is huge yeah check out
this six and a half foot long coach whip
this thing is so gorgeous super fast too
I can't forget the highly venomous
Eastern Diamondback rattlesnake
the colors on this corn snake are
amazing look how red that is beautiful
yeah you guys didn't know about this one
this is a rainbow whip tail and they're
invasive that's so cool oh my god oh he
says they're invasive which means he
slammed it on a rock right after that
[Music]
squeezed
hey if this man's about nature
conservation you gotta you got to get
rid of them them invasive species let's
ask him about that yeah uh yeah
unfortunately he may have been eaten he
may have been eating his bone is at the
bottom of the swamp currently uh working
on getting him on the line hey guys I'm
in the floor check out this invasive
spectacle came and me and my buddies
just wrangled up invasive Cayman
what another every last video
hey guys I'm in the Florida Everglades
check out this invasive spectacle came
and me and my buddies just wrangled up
look at all these this Burmese python
was fast
but not fast enough
huh this little guy really thought he
could Escape fishing Garrett check out
this juicy land crab this thing has a
wife whoa this is a hatchling Burmese
python and this is a monster Burmese
python almost what the [__] come on I
was checking out this 10-foot alligator
and he got awfully close I didn't
realize how many were watching
from Arizona
wait how did he get so close to an owl
that doesn't even make why is that
scarier than any other airport really oh
it doesn't make sense these animals are
hyper aware of their environment yeah
it's a dumbass
come on guys
I love owls I'm just saying this one's
kind of dumb that was so cool
another Everglades video check out this
big 10-foot gecko
you gotta watch where you're walking
around here a scorpion just crawled
across my swamp Stompers check out this
invasive cubanidinal so pretty
look at these freshly hatched Scarlet
snakes they're so gorgeous danger noodle
that's an Eastern Diamondback making a
quick Escape check out this brown water
snake he's native and he's eating an
invasive walking catfish so cool to see
this right here we got another native
green water snake they're non-venomous
love these guys he's got blood on his
hand oh he got bit yeah he already has
blood on his [__] Knuckles yeah this
guy uh does not
have fear no another Everglades video
check out this here's Brian right here
we got another native green water right
they're non-venomous
love these guys he gave me a little kiss
[Music]
that dog on my arm a few months ago
though yeah
pretty incredible guy I gotta say he
needs a show worst Discovery yes I think
he's too dangerous
they would not be okay with this Steve
Irwin conditions bid all the time
I think that he needs a show I think so
I mean it technically has got it already
here on Tick Tock that's true that's
fair I mean look at the views yeah
let's see I want to see what he looks
like here I can see him hey guys today
I'm taking my baby coons down to the
pond it's important that baby raccoons
get to play in water they definitely
learned how to follow their mom getting
bigger and stronger
it's important that they get to play in
the water and learn how to cancel the
Crustaceans and fish as they would in
the wild they're more focused on getting
to their mama and you guys are probably
wondering are there alligators in there
yeah but I spot them every time this is
just a little two-footer my little Trash
Panda by the day hey guys today I'm
taking my baby okay
um what who has baby raccoons yeah
and they follow him so cute I love okay
um he may have fixed his service I got
him in the lobby so I'm gonna let them
in yeah go ahead all right hopefully it
works this time come on
oh
big news
big news hey what's up
I finally got internet man I just
dropped all of a sudden fishing Garrett
what's wrong with you man
oh man I just love my swamp puppies
looking
are you Fearless do you ever get scared
out there yeah uh not not with that kind
of stuff because I grew up doing it my
whole life so it's pretty It comes
naturally I'm not worried about that
kind of stuff at all maybe with some
other animals that I haven't experienced
before because I wouldn't know the
behavior I wouldn't know what to expect
and that would make me act a little bit
more cautious
around the Gators around the snakes
you're not afraid because there are
poisonous snakes out there I mean but
you're you're so confident that they're
you're gonna see them you're you're
never gonna
you're never gonna have an accident you
don't think
um yeah I totally could if I I could
easily make a mistake out there it just
takes one wrong move even with like with
all the experience in the world all it
takes is one wrong step and I could step
on one
but I trust myself that I that I won't
do that but so they you know they they
wouldn't go out of their way to attack
you
oh absolutely not
um they're very they're very calm and a
lot of people have a misconception that
like cottonmouths for example that's
like the main snake I see out there
that's like very abundant something that
you'll run into a lot
they um they're just defensive so you'll
walk up to it and it'll coil up and then
open its mouth and do a defensive
posture
and it's not trying to attack you or
come after you but sometimes people will
walk up to them and they'll scare them
and the snake doesn't know what's going
on and it's just trying to get cover
trying to hide and it'll shoot right
under their feet and they think it's
after them you know what I mean I see
yeah they're like oh my God the snake
attacked me it just went after me so
yeah that that yeah a lot of people get
worried you know when they see that but
it's just them not being familiar but I
always try to tell people that snakes
don't chase you it doesn't happen
why do you do it barefoot
oh I've always I've always liked being
Barefoot I get better grip like right
now for example here I'll switch the
camera I'm walking on these sharp rocks
hmm
yeah but I just I just love being
Barefoot it's really comfortable for me
I get better traction I'm not always
Barefoot there's some situations where
you just absolutely have to wear shoes
but I prefer to be barefoot that's
incredible dude have you ever had any
close calls like what's the the most
harrowing experience you've had out
there
in the Everglades exactly or I mean
nothing too crazy in the Everglades
I've had some really close calls with
alligators but that's just me that's
just me handling them again I don't show
this in Tick Tock a lot but when I
actually handle alligators like I I
actually can
catch them you know and handle them I
don't always put that on Tick Tock but
because I'll get banned you know they're
very sensitive with the community
guidelines
and uh yeah I get some really cool of
doing that sometimes but
it's not too bad
this is what you do for fun you just
Cruise out there I mean what what why
yeah why do you why are you doing it
I just love it I've done my
only reason I'm out in the Everglades is
to move these to Burmese pythons so I'm
sure you've heard of the the giant
pythons that are invading the Everglades
so I go out there and the main goal is
to find these invasive pythons and
remove them out of the ecosystem wow
interesting what do you do with them
so by law you have to humanely euthanize
them really but I yeah if I can legally
get away with keeping them alive and
re-home them to someone that can keep
them then I'll do that but it's not
always an option for me and I have to
you know I have to keep myself out of
trouble but I I'm always looking after
the animal it's not their fault you know
it's people's fault because they release
them oh wow how do you euthanize a snake
I personally don't do it I have someone
else do it I hate killing them I feel
bad yeah um you have to destroy the
brain and that's like the quickest death
form so like a knife behind the head or
anything that will yeah yeah something
like that and I hate that man I don't
like doing that so why is it so
important to get these snakes out of the
Everglade
because they're eating all of the small
mammals so
since the 80s we've received a 90
decline on small mammals so raccoons
possums boxes even the Florida panther
so yeah we're running really low huh the
pythons will kill Panthers
oh yeah a big 17-18 footer could easily
take down holy crap
that's crazy yeah they they eat when the
researchers cut them open they find deer
hoofs in them they eat food
wow so how the hell do you get rid of a
18 foot
snake oh I come up right behind it now
you won't get pick it up
and it's gonna fight back they're very
very powerful but if you're used to
working with snakes and you understand
how to do it you could you you're you
are capable of catching a pretty big
snake with no experience yeah yeah if
you have the confidence you don't know
me
[Laughter]
I've been watching you since I was
little I think oh really thanks yeah
yeah so man I go ahead I've been
watching you guys ever since like back
back in the day with idubbbs and all
that I love you guys oh my god well your
[__] you're awesome I love you your
videos are amazing yeah your videos are
free are so really easy and so wild man
and uh so cool you
um you were you were going on about uh
the invasive snakes you're saying
they're eating why is it important to
keep the mammals
because it's the the Florida Everglades
is a one-of-a-kind ecosystem and it's
really important to keep everything in
check everything natural when you start
taking all these animals out of the food
chain it ruins the balance like right
now like when you when you get rid of
these mammals it just it um messes with
all the other animals too and we have
all kinds of invasive fish I feel bad
for these alligators because the pythons
eat most of their food and now they're
resorted to just eating invasive fish
and you'll see in my videos where the
alligators will bite in the mud they're
trying to catch these minnows because
when I shine a light around them it
scares the fish into them and then they
catch them oh you're hot you guys are
working together huh yeah yeah I'm
trying to help them out and you're
you're technically you know you're not
you really shouldn't feed alligators but
that's like a natural way to get them
food without them knowing it's from me
like if I've walked up to it if I walked
up to the alligator and handed it a fish
you know that alligator would remember
that and he would associate people with
food and that can make them very
dangerous because whenever he sees a
random person he's gonna swim right up
to him not to eat them but just because
he knows that person when he gets close
to him he gets food why wouldn't he why
wouldn't an alligator try to eat
a person generally they don't see people
as food man they they rely on movement
to feed so he might see my leg moving
and they'll respond to any kind of
movement like I could get a stick and
splash it in the water and he'll come
right up to it because he thinks it's
something he can catch they're very
opportunistic and they'll take down just
about anything they can get their mouth
on
and what about like these big ass 18
Footers why why aren't they eating
people
oh they're man they're you'll hear that
they're everywhere and everything but
they're not that easy to find they're
very reclusive they hide deep deep in
the swamp and they don't always come out
so it really takes professionals to find
these things
and they don't really they don't they do
show up in people's yards and stuff
sometimes but they don't really take you
out they'll take out your cat or dog or
something hmm maybe a small child if you
had a small child that could happen but
it had as far as I know it hasn't
happened yet Jesus that's scary and so
when you so there's a lot of these
snakes out there it seems like they're
reclusive like you said but this is like
a huge invasion of them oh yeah there's
more than um there's more than FWC says
for sure they say there's uh I think
over a hundred thousand but I'm I'm very
confident
oh yeah I'm very confident very
confident there's lots more than that
just because you don't find them like I
can come out here during the wrong time
of year in the wrong climate and not
find any for weeks but if I go during
the right time you could find a bunch
it's just I know how good they can hide
and how easy they can go undetected
so that I just know how many I know
there has to be way more than a hundred
thousand according to our numbers a lot
of a lot of the numbers we catch aren't
um I don't always glorify how many
pythons I'm killing I don't like it but
yeah a lot more than I show on social
media how many do you think you're
catching you can be honest with us
yeah yeah 100 I just just don't like
I just don't like killing snakes man but
it has to be done man uh even some of
the yeah even some of the greatest
animal lovers come out here and try to
help out
are you guys do you want to know you
want to know what a bigger problem is
then the pythons yeah
Florida is building houses at such an
alarming rate right now they are wiping
out all the natural ecosystem oh oh wow
yeah it's really really sad like I grew
up I grew up in Southwest Florida and I
everywhere I go now it's huge
construction sites so all the Eastern
Diamondback Rattlesnakes all of the
other
um endangered animals like even the
Florida panther all of its habitat is
messed up because they need really
really big pieces of property and land
to travel to breed and stuff
so it's really sad to see Florida go
downhill like this with so much so much
Land Development I'm all for I'm all for
building houses but they just need to
really limit on where they're building
houses
so there's no like nature
um reservation kind of
there is but they there's not enough
that you can't just make a square of
like
you can't just make a square of
conservation land and expect it to just
be perfect because these animals need
huge areas especially the pan the
panther travels like 100 miles they can
travel really really far
so when you make a big square of land a
lot of these animals just end up
Crossing out of that going to people's
yards going into the road and getting
killed yeah pretty sad so what are these
land developers doing they just scooping
out the swamp land and just putting in
they they they're regulated by the
government and FWC and everything but it
doesn't matter as long as you have the
money you know you can always get things
done it's a shame but how do they do it
because it's swampland right there's a
way to they just remove not not just in
the Everglades mainly the more Uplands
of Florida just like Florida as a whole
okay they go in there and they wipe out
all the trees sometimes they leave a few
trees you know because it looks pretty
to some people but for the most part
everything goes I actually work for an
environmental company called Wetlands
management so we manage swamps and
wetlands we remove invasive plants we do
Wildlife surveys we do gopher tortoise
removal surveys so we go around and we
we relocate these burrowing gopher
tortoises and keep them from getting
killed from the land developers and they
have to pay for it the land developers
okay but I I hate seeing it that's how I
know what's really going on you know
behind the scenes
so what would you like to see done in
terms of housing I mean there's like
massive housing shortages across the
country right yeah
yeah what should we be I would love to
see uh I would love to see them building
more around the cities and
dislike less building in certain areas
yeah it's really hard for me to say
exactly what they should do you know I
don't have all the answers I just know
it's out of control I know one of the
problems here in La is that they're not
building up enough
I don't know if that's a problem and you
know you look at Manhattan or New York
for example you have millions of people
you know because they build up they have
really tall buildings and I don't know
I don't know if that's an option but
yeah that could that could totally be an
option yeah you know go to places like
Tampa or Miami they build up
so are you guys making Headway on on the
snakes uh the invasive snakes there you
and all the people
you're never we're never going to get
rid of them the only thing we can hope
to do is control them I see just control
the population of
and so like is it being done by like
volunteers like you or is there some
kind of there is State a lot of it
doesn't a lot of it doesn't get
mentioned like a lot of it doesn't get
mentioned but there is a lot of people
like me removing them really
yes serious but yeah they have they have
professional python contractors with
um with the Water Management District
and they go and they have a group that
goes in rooms them and FWC is a group
that goes and removes them I see do you
think the I wonder because I know
you know in my city where I'm from yeah
hold on in Israel there's a lot of
building up to the point where people
always complain about it because it's so
ugly and it's so CL it feels
claustrophobic like it's buildings next
to buildings next to buildings but I
guess in a way what you got to do it's
just it's really so tiny you don't
really have an option well then stop
having then you got to stop having kids
yeah if you don't want to build that
yeah you know then stop [__] I love
people but you know I love the animals
too I want to keep them I want to keep
them around I'm just slowly seen it get
worse and worse over the years
so what's the worst case scenario do you
think if you guys if these populations
go unchecked
oh there are
um fwc's already doing that as we speak
there's more than just pythons that are
invasive you know have you ever heard of
the green iguanas ortegers oh you have
the grand iguanas oh I never heard of
that the green iguanas are all over and
FWC just made them illegal to possess so
the only thing you can do is kill them
wow which sounds okay but now that gets
rid of thousands of people that collect
these babies and sell them to other
people out of state and give them a home
out of state where they couldn't survive
so they would have to be taken care of
in captivity
so now nobody's doing that and now the
populations are going to go way out of
control especially with the tegus too
so you think there's some mismanagement
there on the on the gun oh yeah there's
definitely there's definitely the wrong
people in charge I don't know who to
blame but it's definitely
it's definitely not being done right it
seems like the State of Florida
specifically is very
Pro business and I would assume I don't
know but like not very uh
environmentally forward conscious
whatever you know
this is really aren't when it comes down
to it I think everything even if they
they may say they are or whatever they
may promote that they are on like the
news or whatever when it comes down to
it they're all controlled and they're
you know it's all about money when it
comes down to it from what I've
experienced at least let me look around
show me the show me where you're
stomping around there
I'm walking in a circle right now
because I got up to these woods and I
don't want to walk in and lose energy oh
yeah yeah okay I see let me flip it
around yeah so you have baby
um looking around these rocks for maybe
a python or a rattlesnake or something
cool
that'd be awesome
yeah that would be cool I really wish I
could really wish I could find something
for you guys but all my good spots have
no internet uh
wherever you are is the good spot
yeah hey
um
do you accept the moniker of uh
Florida Steve Irwin
uh no I don't want to be I don't want to
be exactly I don't want to be Steve
Irwin see I love Steve Irwin but
everyone throws out this guy Steve Irwin
if you just pick up a snake it doesn't
even have to be me
so I kind of want to be my own person
but I love Steve Irwin I don't think
anyone can live up to his level with
Wildlife but I'd like to get close to it
I stand for the similar things
insanely successful the views you're
getting there are nuts I wonder if
there's anyone uh reaching out to you to
yeah I've had I've had a lot of
different people reaching out I need
help I really I'm kind of a caveman on
the phone I really don't know what I'm
doing I just make little Tick Tock
videos
because I think
um I see that for you I see that
potential for you
yeah
I think he was eating thank you I really
appreciate it
well if you need help we can help you
out I mean I know how to talk yeah I
would love to travel yeah I'm not if you
need to if you have questions or
something or if you if you want uh
I don't know how much connections I have
but I can help you however I can if
whatever if you have questions about
[__] oh man I would really appreciate
that I would just like to I would like
to get off at Tick Tock at some point
because it's mainly entertainment I like
to educate but I can't really get into
depth with the with the um education
side because every time I try to it
doesn't work real well with the views
and the algorithm they just like Fast
action you know what I'm saying right so
I try to get that entertainment but also
give them a little bit of knowledge too
if I can
have you tried YouTube
uh not really not yet I I really need to
I really need to I don't know how to I
don't know how to make videos oh man you
would take off there well I think you're
filming so just you're so good at your
tick tocks I I think it'd be you know
easy for you just watch the footage to
an editor we can find you an editor we
can hook you up yeah yeah I would really
I would really appreciate that because I
really don't know what I'm doing you
know I'm just a guy with the camera oh
dude you have a YouTube for shorts do
you have a YouTube channel plus George
there yeah yeah I have like 4K
subscribers I made a YouTube and I
posted a few things on it
know what I'm doing well you should post
the same Tick Tock videos to YouTube
they'd Crush there too
you think so definitely I see everyone
else is crushing with my videos uh
they're reposting your [__] oh yeah dude
they're they're making Bangs dude good
for them well good for you we got to get
you yeah dude I don't mind I used to
make me upset when I would see people
get a lot of views and I'm just like no
one tagged me but I don't care anymore
I'll get recognized by it eventually I
mean it's true it's all your content but
I do think that uh it'd be really easy
to convert hey tell me what pets you
have
I actually don't have a lot right now I
did rehabilitate so you know we had that
hurricane in come through dude it hit
Englewood Florida so directly it like I
I live on 20 acres there my family has
property over there and it devastated
that whole area so bad man
so I got a I got a lot of people
bringing me baby raccoons I
rehabilitated a lot of animals like
almost any any animal you can think of
so I had baby raccoons for a while and
they've been they've completely grown up
and I was banned on Tick Tock for seven
months so I didn't do any updates or
videos with them or anything
but I had some raccoons and now they're
in the wild why'd you get banned for
doing dangerous stuff
I don't know I posted oh I posted a crab
video these big giant land crabs that
are in the keys and then that got banned
and then I posted a fishing video at the
short fishing video and then that got
banned and then they just deleted my
whole account and then I didn't they
were so bad with uh helping me like help
like reaching out I could never get a
good answer from them and I could never
like predict what would happen with my
Tick Tock every day every time I post
I'm like shaking I'm like oh this could
be it that's you know I love it they've
been a lot better but that is the scary
thing about it but you know with tick
tock's uh future in an uncertain spot we
got to make sure you get somewhere where
you can diversify yeah you got to
diversify dude
yeah yeah I really need to I'm gonna
have to move to YouTube or something
else I don't know exactly I'm so I'm not
very good online not gonna lie
we'll figure it out we're gonna help I
really appreciate it yeah yeah yeah I
have some big plans I want to go to the
Amazon rainforest
actually I was planning on going to on a
trip to Peru with some buddies and we're
gonna look for green anacondas and we're
gonna do research on them wow that's
correct so I'm gonna help out some
researchers and just film everything
just film everything
yeah dude I'm gonna try I'm gonna even
if you don't know what you're gonna do
with it or where you're gonna put it
just film everything
oh I will man there's a whole lot of
content I don't post
there's trust me man I've been I've been
uh doing this ever since I was literally
so much I don't record and post like
that's the difference between me because
a lot of these people like
they have exotic pets and they can
always make content but they didn't
start when they were young you know they
weren't handling real wildlife so
there's there's definitely a big
difference with that I just hope I can
capitalize on it and better help the
ecosystem and promote Wildlife properly
um I think that's the beautiful thing is
that you also have a good message with
like amazing content so
I think it's great yeah I really
appreciate it you are I'm actually
hosting I'm actually posting a tick tock
right now I had a crazy night in the
Everglades man I got bit by a water
scorpion when I was so I was standing
next to this 10-foot alligator and he
was under the water and he was right by
my foot and he was looking at my foot so
I'm watching him and I take a step back
and I step on a water scorpion it bites
me on the leg
and I was like oh what the heck bit me
and I look at my foot and it's bleeding
look up a water scorpion or like toe
biter I'll pull it up you'll see you'll
see this crazy looking bug
you say you're not scared when
alligators is chilling like right next
to you
no no I'm watching him and I can I can
judge his body language if he wanted to
get me I could for pretty pretty
certainly guarantee if he was gonna
lunge forward like I'll even watch the
back legs like let's say let's say he
does want a lunch for me he's going to
position himself to lunch so I'll see
that positioning by judging his body
language and then know oh I better watch
the watch the [__] out is this the thing
that got you can you see it yeah yeah
there it is that's it that dude dude
that thing that thing has a a wild thing
yeah it's a little devil for sure man
I'm always paranoid about him but like
like you think I'm worried about the
alligators I'm worried about stepping on
one of those because so is this your is
this your arch nemesis out there would
you say oh yeah dude especially during
the rainy season they're everywhere and
I just step on them yo dude I think I
build up a tolerance to the to the bite
and the poison but it's still still
pretty wild is this the same bug
yeah that's it oh my God that's it man
hell no
yeah dude they're intimidating
yeah so um
I don't like that for you I'm looking at
this bug still
Our Lives
so here's what I wanna I I need you can
you hear me we had a little uh we lost a
little reception there but I think we're
good I need you yeah to diversify and I
need you to get some kind of show
especially with Medics so they can go
with you so you don't die because I'll
be honest bro I know you're like a pro
but like something's gonna happen right
don't you feel like eventually
Something's Gonna go wrong
something could I'm gonna try my best
not to I know I never really get hurt
but yeah I could totally make a mistake
and I doubt it would be with alligators
it'd probably be with venomous snakes if
you look at my Instagram it's the same
name fishing gear it has uh pictures of
me holding Eastern Diamondback
Rattlesnakes up to my face and that's
far more dangerous than the alligators
because if I got bit by that that would
kill me so fast why would you put it to
yourself
because I love it it's stupid I don't
recommend people doing it but it's just
something I like to do I love them I
know it I know I'm not going to get bit
by it I could but I'm judging the
behavior like I said you know
just like Steve Irwin did Steve Irwin
never got bit by a snake he got bit he
got the stingray came out of nowhere
that was like a freak accident and see
something like that could happen to me
that's true but it's amazing yeah how
many animals he handled without getting
bit he's far above me with that
with way more venomous snakes like it
won't last 10 minutes if you get bit by
some of the snakes he was handling oh he
was doing even crazier [__] huh
yeah for sure man than anyone
but I think I could I would totally
handle some of the crocodiles and do all
that stuff that he does I haven't really
seen him do anything that I wouldn't do
but I would need to experience the
animal more before I'm confident in
doing that I could always wing it but
you know I don't wanna uh too quick no
don't Wing stuff please dude
how old are you
I'm 23. okay
all right you got a lot of time oh
you're on my Instagram did you see that
yeah we're seeing the video where I
stick my hand in the alligator's mouth
oh I did no yeah that was actually a
very long time that was a very long time
ago when I did that one
and this is a while I was doing that
when I was like 12.
yeah yeah parents get scared I don't
really work with uh you pulling that up
Dan yeah they used to they used
they used they've gotten over it my
mom's used to she used to get all
worried but she's okay now that's just
that's just like usually when people do
this it's like a trained animal
actually so when they do it when they do
it um with when they do it with the
alligators that are in the farms and
everything it's the exact same thing the
alligator is still like we'll still bite
you the same way as a wild one a wild
one will just be more jumpy and
sometimes not broken in and sometimes
react differently but when it comes to
that bite it's all the same yo you would
crush on Facebook too I have no question
the Boomers would eat that [__] up
brother
God I can't believe you're sitting on
like this content Empire I mean look how
good it good it does on Tick Tock what
do we do what are we gonna do for him
yeah what can we do I would like to get
financially stable I live in a trailer
right now really are you making a little
bit of money from Tick Tock with those
views I know it's not a lot
I think the past past month I've been
back I've made maybe maybe 10K uh
nothing crazy over what period of time
um over the past like two and a half
months oh I heard something
there's something right over here take
me home take me
I hope it's a panther
I can't it's a little uh sorry what were
you saying
no it's just listening to you I I
I'm walking around I'm looking what did
you think what do you think you heard
out there
I don't know
I've had some crazy experiences out in
the woods before like I know every
single animal sound I know exactly like
when I hear a noise just by the bushes I
can usually tell you what it is just by
how the bushes rustled because certain
animals walk a certain way through the
woods and you can recognize that after a
long time of experience
and I've heard some crazy noises before
that I can't tell you what they were hmm
like I've heard screams like deep like
guttural screams and
weird like wood knocking and it's really
suspicious does that freak you out when
you hear something you don't know what
it is like that yeah it it does it does
make me worry because I don't know what
it is and I'm curious and I want to get
closer and figure out what it is because
if I can get a video of whatever I'm
hearing that would be awesome right do
the um I have a question do the Pumas
out there do they have like that crazy
scream
um here in California we have mountain
lions which I know are like related and
they yeah when they scream it sounds
like a woman being like murdered with a
knife it's like the craziest sound yeah
I've heard them fighting in the woods
before and it is insane it took me a
while to figure out exactly what it is
because it's such a rare sounding here
too fighting right because they're
already rare animals in general so to
hear tube fighting was crazy and that
took me a minute to figure out what it
was but I you know I eventually did but
no they they make uh the Panthers here
make a little bit of a different sound
and it's not too common to hear um them
being very vocal they usually do little
chirps little chirp sounds to
communicate
cute dude you are you are
the man you are so talented and brave
and knowledgeable I want good things for
you
oh thank you I really appreciate it like
I said dude I've been watching you since
I was a little kid so it's really great
to meet you I'm like oh I want to meet
that guy one day I want to meet you Ida
filthy Frank
yeah yeah those were the days man Hey
listen um who's it is Zach you're in
touch with them oh yeah you guys have
email okay
um let's we let's chat afterwards let's
see what we can do for you I want to
help you out
I can't wait to like go and follow you
and watch all your videos yeah yeah yeah
thank you so much yeah yeah hey um if
you guys ever have me on at night and
I'm in a certain situation I can
basically give you a whole Tick Tock
button over the live oh that was crazy
yeah yeah it would be very easy to set
up as long as it's night time like
because a lot of the all my action all
the action out here in the Everglades
happens at night okay I was gonna ask
why you do it at night but I'm assuming
that's right everything's nocturnal like
did you know like deer and rabbits and
almost every mammal they're all
nocturnal oh dear no and rabbits Yes
dear Rapids they're all not girl of
course deer come out that's why hunters
will hunt them early in the morning
because they're coming out you know
because that's when the deer is still
out and then right before dark because
that's when they start to come out
so we're the only idiots walking around
in the daytime
to help them out
what do you think about this wild animal
right here oh it looks like the Gator
Foods yeah I was gonna say do you think
he'd survive in the Everglades oh no man
he wouldn't make it a day yeah you know
the car a car would hit him dude people
run over all the wildlife here it's so
disgusting is there such I just saw a
pin I just saw a 10-foot alligator
killed in the road how how do you hit a
10-foot alligator it's huge what how do
you not see it I would assume people
around there know too to keep an eye out
yeah I know dude they did run them over
and it's really dangerous if you're
gonna hit something like that it could
kill your whole family you might as well
hit a brick wall oh yeah
what kind of dog do you got there
he's like Alfredo he's a mix we don't
really know exactly because he was
adopted but it's like a Yorkie Maltese
something
cute so um listen Garrett thank you it
was a treat and everybody we've got
fishing Garrett that's you on Tick Tock
that's you on Instagram that's your
handle everywhere
yes sir fishing Garrett nice I think we
got and we got to get you set up on uh
his YouTube by the way to the chat so oh
influx of Subs wait where's what's this
it's just fish and Garrett on YouTube I
think we got to get you set up on
Facebook and YouTube yeah
musical there I I really I would really
appreciate it I need help I don't know
what I'm doing I just know how to handle
the animals that's about it that's it
I'm learning you know um also
on YouTube shorts they're not as
they're not as militant you know I don't
think you're going to worry about
getting banned all the time oh that's
awesome yeah maybe I can step it up a
little bit Yeah you could post stuff if
I'm gonna if I'm gonna be completely
honest my videos are very nerfed
compared to what I actually do off
camera so I think all those alligators
all those alligators I could handle them
and I could do all kinds of crazy stuff
but I also want to find that
intermediate where I don't want to be
harassing them you know what I mean I
don't want to like a lot of people think
that I am when I'm really not I don't
want them to think I'm just going there
and just just to mess with the gator you
know I'm really just looking for pythons
and their Gators everywhere and I'm just
walking around them saying hi to them
they they never seem to mind they're
always they always uh watch me you know
and keep their distance and never attack
me
yeah one thing I would recommend that
you could do right away is you can you
there's like a it's a website or yeah
there's a few websites you can remove
the tick tock Watermark and then just
upload okay good just upload all your
videos to YouTube dude
okay okay yeah those will take off
I've done it a few times and I get like
a thousand views and oh my God it's not
worth it it yeah it takes I think it
takes a minute but maybe maybe a little
bit of consistency yeah yeah yeah yeah
but anyway
um we'll talk we'll talk uh yeah man
keep in contact so
um guys check out fishing Garrett
support him this guy's going places he's
the real deal
[Applause]
holy smoke so awesome man so nice to
meet you yeah yeah man great to meet you
guys too all right stay safe out there
we'll talk yes sir I'm gonna I'm gonna
be out here tonight wish me luck all
right hey if I die I'm posting a video
right now so if I die okay if you've got
what's the best way to find your body if
you disappear in the Everglades oh you
won't man the alligators will eat it up
that sounds like a pretty cool way to go
honestly so an alligator would eat your
dead body but not your live body
it could it could attack me yeah it
totally could but for the most part
alligators are really peaceful I promise
and it's in the wrong situation did you
actually hear about that 85 year old
lady that got taken out by the alligator
in Florida 85 year old now I do yeah the
whole elderly lady just got got yoinked
she got yoinks what happened she just
wasn't fast enough
she was she made a big mistake something
you'd never want to do in Florida a lot
of these Northerners they move down here
and they're not aware with all the
Alligators and they go over to anybody
of water is probably gonna have an
alligator in it and that's fine you
don't need to be scared but you just
need to keep an eye you know when you're
when you're near the water's edge just
keep an eye I'm knocking on your door
but it'll be in the water just chilling
being an alligator look at this okay
they arrested the alligator bro yeah
dude they they got that thing dude I
feel bad for it yeah what did he do
right yeah he's under arrest you got
arrested for being an alligator yes so
so what was the mistake she made
she was not paying attention and I she
knows she's probably very old and I
don't blame her necessarily for it but
it was very preventable the alligator
shooting across the pond on the top of
the water it sees the dog okay it wants
that little dog kind of a dog like the
one you have
and the alligator comes right after the
dog climbs up the bank the dog runs runs
away it's on a leash but it runs kind of
out of the way of the alligator the
alligator just grabs the nearest thing
close to it which was the lady's leg and
just drug her right in the water
and if the video Cuts but it definitely
uh
I wonder if um old you know how they say
like old lobsters taste don't it taste
as good because like the meat is less
tender I wonder if that's true that's
true for an alligator I wonder if that's
true of humans
the oldie yeah yeah the perfection
yeah yeah I just wonder you know it's
kind of interest because she's pretty
old I mean it's no whiskey yeah Oak
Barrel
so she was walking a dog or something
like that yeah she was walking a small
yeah you can probably pull up a video
they're all over
that's something you're not supposed
to dog in there you never want to walk
your small dogs or any dogs next to the
next to the side of a pond in Florida
and if you do at least be aware of your
surroundings and look around the
alligator is not going to come from
underneath the water and shooting out at
you it's gonna see you far away and
slowly work its way over it's watching
that dog it doesn't care about you it
sees that small mammal and it's just
after it it sees that that small
movement you know what I mean oh here oh
wow once the alligator is already
shooting towards her here's a picture
just to give you an idea of what she was
doing that seems really yeah yeah
no oh them
we're back
our streaming computer froze is that
right that's right it's the second time
it's happened and the line I think it
was like a month ago that this happened
so um
going to have to investigate but we're
back are we back and good
uh we will be in a moment
so uh we uh Garrett
Garrett was eaten during the year yeah
unfortunately watching them die yeah he
was yanked into the water
really tough watch yeah it was rough
I felt bad but you know what that's just
how it is himself you know it's it's
always a possibility so you said I'm the
invasive species right
what a [__] interesting dude huh yeah
for real that guy's awesome that was
like
um awesome that guy is awesome love him
oh there's breaking news about Tate
big news he was released from prison oh
boy big news oh boy released on house
arrest I saw an article that said
David had like they were eavesdropping
in prison he was com admitting to do a
bunch of crimes like I just read that
yeah I saw that too yeah I don't I don't
know the validity of that I didn't read
all of it but I'm seeing footage of them
walking out Andrew and his brother you
know what they're on house arrest that
means they'll have access to their
cameras again so
can expect a oh yeah great content soon
you know what
they're so boring now so over them
L it's like I get your Stick Dude I'm so
smart you're just you're just boring
like I talked to one of your produce
days Sebastian that's who you're sending
out into the world
not that interesting let me think about
it hold on
there's a [__] loser a bunch of
losers friends I just want to be left
alone
just leave them alone
the one time he had any opposition from
anyone confident was Hassan
and he started crying about
to kick him from the group
that's right I forgot about that the
only time it was great he's ever
not sat in a giant circle jerk
and had any opposition at least
Sebastian had some courage to come in
here and talk to somebody
with opposing perspective
oh yeah he's boring [__] loser who
Tate just got released I guess to um
house arrest
but I mean the investigation still
ongoing I'm assuming yeah he's just
gonna wait in his house
seems like it yeah what's that article
though that we read a b
um you linked it you know uh I don't
think that that was actually new
information I remember telling you about
that a few weeks ago it was a it was a
translation from a Romanian article can
you read it I just want because I
thought it was interesting I don't think
I had seen it before God this [__]
salt is hot right that same thing
happened to me I was trying to kill this
burrito real fast I was like hmm the red
salsa looks so good it is good and they
poured it all over it and then I it's
hot as I thought oh it's spicy burning
in their butthole
can you find that yeah I'm looking for
it
oh
hold on guys so somebody is asking is a
boba time I'm dumb
ah it's so hot
uh the news from Romania uh they wiretap
Tate's phone calls in jail the
conversations he planned to escape to
Dubai ordered the intimidation of
witnesses and tried to bring uh bribe
Romanian politicians they found four
instances from the last two years were
Tate bribe police to escape charges of
human trafficking Expo they found it huh
that must have been a real they were a
real gumshoes loose to figure that one
out he literally bragged about it
constantly
uh so he bribed police to escape human
trafficking exposed him for lying uh
about having cancer and a lot more
uh he was trying to fly directly to
Dubai
um he told Luke to call a shake and
order a private jet for the same day he
had a 30-day hearing so he could fly
directly to Dubai
prosecutor said he wanted to leave
because he wouldn't be allowed to leave
the country well yeah uh defense says
that he wants to go to buy only for
medical treatment and not flea same day
the cancer reports leaked uh right so
they were like orchestrating that whole
thing to try and get an excuse to fly
him to another country is what it sounds
like
uh uh yada yada yada anyway that that's
that was the juiciest little stuff but
yeah I mean I guess they just they have
them on tape admitting to a bunch of a
bunch more crimes so why did they love
you he loves talking about his crimes on
recordings
far more fun wait so why did they
release him is there any details about
that
uh release him on house arrest
um
well I mean he hasn't actually been
convicted of anything so I mean you
I guess because they can hold him
indefinitely yeah without charge he's
been there for three months yeah and he
had two uh unsuccessful appeals applied
just recently lost another one of those
appeals but um I don't know let's see
Bucharest uh court of appeal ruled in
favor of their appeal okay so he
appealed it uh which challenged the
judge decision to last week to extend
his arrest for a fourth time for 30 more
days
um they won their Appeal on Friday and
remain under house arrest until the 29th
of April
uh
uh none of them have yet been formally
indicted so yeah that's the thing it's
like there's not well anyway to really
keep them indefinitely for
they're just gonna get off you think
I mean I don't know the first thing
about the Romanian justice system so who
who knows I mean it seems like no right
because he like admits to all his crimes
repeatedly on tape that seems bad for
him I mean if the judge authorized that
many extensions it's got to be pretty
damning evidence yeah I would think so
um yeah I mean
I'd say it's more likely that they they
sneak out of the country somehow that
they do for me to Dubai or something
like that and you can't get extradited
look at this [__] I am
tweeted this out welcome home Brothers
it must be a coincidence you guys got
out on the same day the Matrix came out
that must be a coincidence no I'm
starting to believe they have nothing to
do with the Matrix for the record
Bradley is supporting and why wait
Bradley don't do that
no he can't let it go there's no such
thing
there's better people to ride for
Bradley
no you really don't need to do that
I wonder if they'll be able to make
videos though or if there's some kind of
uh
Welch in order I was curious about that
too they might not be able to
yeah this house arrest also mean like
you cannot be in the public eye bro
social media look at this meme that was
posted under his
stop listening to celebrities their
literal satanists not except him
Mel Gibson the F who's known for being
basically anti-semitic and racist they
put Satanist over Rihanna
like what this is America I hope you get
R worded by a pack of n words on video
to his wife does this not feel like uh
maybe it's supposed to be ironic or
something
it's so over the top I mean yeah it's
hard to tell no this is this is I mean
this is real
I mean here it says you literally follow
a guy that got arrested for sex driving
he responded and then got released on no
charges
no charges yet
okay whatever they're boring losers
idiots
was it good click bait even to like talk
about it you know I don't think so at
this point probably probably is
it's good hate rage bait maybe but I'm
like not sure
it beats the people that don't like us
yeah yeah God my mouth's on fire it's
giving me like spicy hot chips [__]
yeah
this is a good new sound bite oh that's
what the show looked like when the
computer crashed people at home were
hearing
oh God why is it so [__] hot dude
we have those coconut popsicles if you
want one thank you it's starting to cool
off now
I'm good on that thank you though
stay strong with hardship comes ease
with hardship comes
alhamdulillah
[Music]
yeah the Muslims are coming out in
support of our boy you know personally I
kind of wonder if he made some
connections over there that are uh
trying to help him out get out of there
the Muslims yeah some of those Rich ass
people in Dubai that's a really good
theory I mean he's obsessed with getting
out to Dubai right yeah there was a lot
of people when they first walked out
screaming out in alhamdulillah and all
this stuff so
I don't know he's a prophet
he got in before we know it he'll be in
uh Mecca
may Allah awaken the people
[Music]
love it man love how he's become like a
religious icon to some of them
that's our boy
there was a Andrew Tate character on
South Park last night
I saw a picture of it and I haven't
watched South Park in so long
I don't think I could ever get back into
it to be honest
it's like an ex-girlfriend just
would you ask I asked is that good to
Zach I thought it was it was funny it
was like
um
Randy the character Stan's dad was like
trying to show Stan what it's like to to
be a man and it was just very fitting
that they'd have an Andrew take
character so it played on all that's
going on in the manosphere very exciting
guys they're getting out of prison look
at this alhamdulillah
no sound I guess
boy they look like [__] I should have
sound oh it does yeah
everything's up on my end this is up
hmm
is it muted
oh interesting now it's not even loading
for me no there's no sound
they look confused these guys have been
traumatized bro
this man looks like he just got out of
like
prisoner of war look at his ass he's got
like that A Thousand Mile stair Tristan
that's weird I could hear it
dude they do not look mentally well
and then he's the one that called me
ugly right
he did yeah
you're not looking too odd you know kind
of a mess
all right well at least they can shower
shave
you know
good for them
mashallah
yo what the [__] how did he win them
over so fast these dudes have been
Muslim for like a week before they went
to prison yeah I have no clue and now
they're all riding for him like damn
it's that easy [__] I'm gonna have to
convert if I get her in trouble
hmm
well I'm dead alive
he did a Rebrand he rebranded it's good
it's a hot Rebrand you think people
would come for me if uh if I converted
real fast maybe if I got in trouble uh
possibly harder sell huh no I know I
mean they'll accept you but as soon as
you [__] up then that's it
what do you mean Andrew Tate's like he's
like a prophet already
not like generally speaking Yeah Yeah
just a book a month because these
[__] weirdos yeah I don't know
[Music]
who Tate and his brother Tristan have
left prison in Bucharest they have been
moved to House Nutrition such a
bridesmaid he's like such a little
[__] beta boy
you know
nobody cares about Tristan
did he even convert
loser idiot he's not even Muslim
probably
I mean they got a two for one special I
think he probably did he probably does
whatever his brother does that's true
that is true well whatever any other
Clips we should watch for the juice I
guess love for the [__] you know for
the clip I guess send it I mean
it's a bunch of idiots being dumbasses
and again it doesn't mean he's innocent
of anything he's under house arrest
they held him for as long as they could
mm-hmm
kept putting them under house Rush bro I
don't care if he's acquitted I've seen
the [__] videos of my own eyes
you know
I like Bradley but I just don't know how
y'all how you can watch that video yeah
and then be like Andrew Tate is dope
I'm still like him
um
I don't get it it's a shame
is it is it cowardice
or what is it that makes them it might
be that they're afraid of going against
the the manosphere it's true they would
lose every they would yeah everything if
they went against it let's see
Christian's tweeting he says my brother
has received thousands of letters from
Muslim supporters around the world not a
single Christian has sent me a letter
I'm sure that's not true
I can not real we have owls like
Hogwarts that's funny as hell dude no
can you tell the religion of a
the Christians horrible letter writers
they don't like they're not pen pals
like my Muslim supporters we love them
I feel like at this point like if you're
still following him or supporting him in
any way it's kind of like a beta move
yeah because it's showing you don't have
the balls to go against that's right it
is and Bradley I like Bradley he's a
nice guy but you know we showed you you
know you no there's only you're like
you're like admiring him on socials
but okay whatever he's old news like
it's [__] boring
if you see anything else you want me to
react to just let me know should we put
it in the title
what would that juice the title do you
think
what date yeah
I guess I'm gonna go get hate Watchers I
love Halo anytime you put his name in
anything if it's getting more views it's
100 it's not our audience that's like
rushing to watch it love that a thousand
percent just all of his videos but it's
so awesome they're just coming you know
but so maybe we should because I don't
do people care about Gwyneth Paltrow we
could probably get rid of that one it's
the [__] trial of the century Tonight
guy oh you guys sorry Olivia it sounds
like she's being a little
um girl boss over there in the court so
that doctor was a [__] idiot so let's
talk about it let's go move on to that
why are we talking about it let's just
put it back guys when we got a girl boss
at court talk about slaves okay well
first of all I'm not a fan of Gwyneth
sure that woman puts ozone up her ass
yeah
okay and she sells a bunch of holistic
yeah we're not necessarily into the goop
but she can't dress but she did and this
guy this was totally frivolous uh from
the minute I saw we talked about it on
Monday I think and it was just so
frivolous and pathetic what this guy was
trying to do to her
and uh so I haven't so I would like to
see yeah I'll tell you but
so she counters so he sued her
they had a collision while skiing okay
and he says he had like lifelong
injuries suited for three million
dollars
now the judge immediately was like
that's too much money 300 000. okay
which is funny because you know how much
the lawsuit cost this is a jury trial
300 days 300 is still a lot of money 300
000 on its own yeah illegal defense will
cost a lot more than that the legal
defense will cost more than that for
a jury trial for eight days bro that's
crazy yeah and so Gwyneth uh
counter-sued for one dollar and
attorneys fees and she won a million
bucks
oh yeah because for her attorney so this
guy is [__] and good for him I hate
people that abuse the legal system
surprise surprise suing for one dollar
yeah she's being a boss
I feel like don't you I feel like that's
totally something you would have done in
that situation for sure because she's
making a point about the money yeah [__]
you yeah yeah
seven days sorry Elaine Christian thank
you so much for the gifted but before we
move on let's just change the title to
Andrew Tate uh release these nuts
do you want to actually change it what
can we do it because I want to do this
possible that is pretty funny release
these nuts okay you guys like that one
yeah here's YouTube okay with that nuts
release these nuts I don't know it's
just nonsense it is bald maybe it's
vulgar maybe it's vulgar for a title
that's what I'm saying yeah probably
these nuts my mom
[Laughter]
these nuts these nuts thank you Shreya
taiwari
okay so somebody said she's awful and
the trial was a rich or it went away I
wanted to read it but it went away if
there's space you can keep Gwyneth the
trial was a rich person circus
I mean that is what legal stuff is like
it's not her fault it's insanely
expensive dude it's not her fault also
stupid yeah she is Rich would you rather
her take a bunch more money or take one
Buck I think it's kind of a boss move
for a super rich person to be like I
just need a dollar she she threw The
Gauntlet at this guy he was abusing the
system and she [__] [__] slapped him
and that's good yeah apparently Taylor
Swift also had done that before the one
dollar counter Sue thing that's
everything to me
foreign
even had a chance to counter Sue I don't
think I would ever Sue anybody you know
I just want the fees which we won I
guess technically that's counter suing
for attorneys fees I don't know not
really though
it's more of a motion so uh Andrew Tate
uh released
these
news not can we say nuts do you think
it's kind of it's testable if we're
gonna clickbait we should just ride
reads from release from jail right
agutate released from jail because I
want to insult him in the title if
possible
release from jail it sounds like he's
free and he's doing good you know right
that's not really what we're about
bless you excuse me
[Applause]
oh God Andrew
um
Andrew Tate on house arrest
the nuts are calling
you know it to be true Andrew Tate is
released these nuts
released from
thank you a little thinking music
legitimately chat gbt will have a good
one
don't [__] make fun of me you guys
this is the future you're gonna ask it
uh what we should title the episode yeah
can you suggest a Snappy YouTube title
um
YouTube title about Andrew Tate being
released
from prison
I mean it doesn't have the current event
but
[Music]
okay this is the old one I don't [__]
with you oh my god loser get it together
can you suggest hate on the loose
somebody suggested hey what paid on the
loose
here's a title somebody suggested Trump
arrested Tate released
that next that's pretty spicy I like The
Duality yeah Trump
arrested
Tate release yeah
and we're dropping Gwyneth mom I want a
vape
somebody keeps asking in the comments
what lipstick I'm using
and I gotta shout it out because I'm
obsessed it's YSL when it's redeemed
when it's redeemed oh see gtp4 gave me a
title you will never say the name
gpt4 that's what I said no
Freedom
look at this it does has no context the
title they gave me is freedom Unleashed
Andrew Tate's triumphant return from
prison oh my God I know it's best
Freedom Unleashed
#career over rewrite shut down this
podcast him getting out
of jail is really bad news
Dark Days Ahead Andrew takes unfortunate
release from prison
getting better scared Emoji oh it's
powerful okay
dark days ahead Dark Days Ahead rewrite
it but it's funny and dark
jailbreak Jester Andrew Tates
hilariously dark prison release crying
laughing emoji in school
rewrite it but only use emojis
[Laughter]
wow okay this is I mean that's not
exactly what I asked for but interesting
that's lots of emojis
that's pretty impressive
rewrite it
rewrite it with less words and more
emojis
he's thinking I got him his ass stumped
uh lost for words right now emojis in
the description
this looks like one of those copy paste
yeah one of the sexy copy paper yeah
okay that's it Tate's return exclusive
subscribe hashtag Andrew Tate hashtag
okay the King on lot on leak unlocked
and this is pretty good I gotta say am I
pressed
Andrew Tate released from these
right next
I kind of like it
you updated it let me see what is it
and no not that bro you're gonna [__]
you're gonna Crush our algorithm
don't do that okay
how about Andrew Tate released from
these do we like that I love that I know
you love that love
I do but uh it's not as big an SEO oh
wow there's a dwell there yeah okay but
I like Tate released
it was Trump arrested yeah Trump
arrested Kate released a sulfur but
still a loser Gwyneth Gwyneth redeemed
uh you got me you got money
from Arrested Tate
released I feel like there's a rhyme
there ask it to make it rhyme
chat would do it
Trump arrested a make a rhyming
make a rhyme make this rhyme a rhyme
with this line
Trump arrested
and uh
okay release release
politro
Trump arrested Tate released the world's
in shock to say the least
whoa
we watched the drama like a feast wow
dude that's yeah
we're feasting on the drama y'all yeah
so true
the popcorn out
how about this wait we could actually
just Trump arrested Tate released we
watched the drama like a feast
is that a good time
it's kind of next level love what do you
think
I like it I like it I mean it could just
it could just be the two like the first
sentence yeah that could be which was
yeah somebody in the chat
it's a little corny it's kind of the
world's upset the world's in shock to
say the least is kind of so funny
it sounds so corny though what a poem
that is to say the least rewrite it
rewrite it but make it even funnier
Trump arrested Tate set free a Twist of
Faith oh cat you see the world's a stage
a comedy we laugh and gasp at this Grand
spree that one's not a dog [__]
socks that one sucks idiot I'm gonna
write that that sucks idiot
there's more robot he's gonna kill us
though here's another version okay a
couple arrested Tate on cage this news
has left the world a maze a turn of
events quite deranged we chuckle as
their paths are staged
keep working on it keep working on a
robot think about it and come back to me
idiot
I love the idea of like abusing your
robot
it remembers everything
nobody loves you idiot stop
I don't he says I don't have feelings
but my purpose is to assist
[Music]
if it hasn't been helpful please let me
know
I'll do my best
oh really
oh really I heard someone's feelings
your best is just not good enough
do better I apologize
if you have any other questions feel
free to ask and I'll do my best to help
I said
your best is not good enough
don't have anything else to say [__]
I apologize you just you suck dude this
guy's an idiot you can't have any fun
with these things man be careful dude
when they take over you're gonna be
first you're gonna be on the list he's
like oh yeah March 31st [__] where were
you at 3 23 p.m PST
so Trump arrested hate release we
watched the drama like a feast is that
so dumb it's very dumb now that I hear
it again
with no context it's still dumb it's so
dumb Chad is saying Gwyneth Unleashed
okay okay okay
okay Trump arrested Tate released
Gwyneth Paltrow is Unleashed yeah that's
that's pretty hardcore
maybe we should do all of our titles
rhyming now
so
okay what is it
wrong foreign
we need a filler we need a trump well as
Olivia said Trump arrested tape released
Gwyneth Paltrow is Unleashed Unleashed
oh there it is there it is
my ears they ate that right up okay does
that fit it's a lot of typing
[Music]
Dennis
okay love do you co-sign that what do
you think
hi Coastline let's [__] give it a
ride baby we did it we're not here
rhyming I support Jenna sadly what if um
you're trying to get into the us and
you're making statements like that and
you've got it this is that slander I
said I support genocide you want to
unpack I do not support genocide guys uh
you got me that is taken out of context
somebody got love really good on it
suddenly
yeah yeah someone I like I thought I was
like being nice to this person helping
her win an argument with her friend
Janice
so I did say I support space Janice
side that's awesome
I'm on genus
that was a good one that was a good one
you know like the whole thing with like
these nut jokes I love that but my whole
stream or my whole shot is people just
trying to get me with these nut jokes so
that was a little bit too far all the
time yeah like multiple times a day yeah
Trump arrested Tate release Gwyneth
Paltrow is Unleashed
straight podcast
Dr Seuss version what if uh we kept it
on theme and said legally Unleashed
because then you know it's still she's
it's on the theme of uh getting arrested
and released legally in Gwyneth paltrows
legally Unleashed legally Unleashed
I don't know just don't know any words
yeah I had chat GPT make a make a diss
track on you
oh [__] yo we had a plan we had a show
to do but Ethan man he just blew right
through focused on his YouTube channel
didn't have a clue that ignoring the doc
would just be so uncool
wow I'm cool that's pretty impressive
all right how about this how about this
write a diss track about my friend a b
this could get real dark bro how dark
should I get he's about okay
he's about to fight
a
huge dude named dad and he's definitely
gonna lose also he is always looking for
a clout
in any situation baby all right let's
see let's just uh
verse one yo listen up it's time to talk
about a b the type of friend who's
always hungry for some clout you see
he's got big fight coming up man it's
pretty sad stepping in the ring against
a giant name bad
a B's chasing Cloud he's gonna fall in
the battle with that he ain't got no
chance at all
gonna lose oh it's such a shame but
we're here to roast him it's all part of
the game
hey
Amy's in the spotlight but it's gonna
fade as he faces a monster that he and
that can't be swayed he's looking for
retention and it's gonna cost cause
isn't this fight with that he's about to
get tossed
it's got a bridge it has mine has a
response to yours really yo did you copy
you should copy paste that in it says
Ethan why you gotta be like that
ignoring our plans and focusing on your
stats titling your videos chasing after
views but what about your friends man we
feel used oh
which friend is that that feels used
he's searching for cloud and every
situation but the writing's on the wall
it's a clear indication he's gonna lose
and that's a guarantee but we're here to
tell the story for all to see yes yes
chasing Cloud but he's gonna fall in a
battle with that he ain't got no chance
at all he's gonna lose oh it's such a
shame but we're here to roast them it's
all part of the game
so wait be my friend it's time to face
the facts you're in a losing battle no
time to relax yeah we'll keep it real we
won't sugarcoat the truth remember it's
all love as we step in the booth
I love we thought we were home as we
thought we were right but now we see the
famous all you got in sight leaving us
hanging feeling like a clown while
you're out here chasing that YouTube
crown
why you're so short yeah this my mind's
fitted all at once I just wasn't ringing
all at once so here it's Pace me that
and then I'll have him respond to yours
I'm gonna probably make a response to
this
AI rap battles yo y'all thought this
[__] was lame
oh you did get a whole thing eh
you didn't read it all
okay I'm gonna make a river so here
so yeah this bit is hard this is the one
I did the rice gum one too
yeah here is his response to our
uh
to our
how did we call it
rap battle
to our diss track
can you create a diss track in response
to his response
amazing make it super mean
make it super mean and go hard as you
can
all right here we go
verse one Yahweh be you're back with a
track to this but let me tell you man is
full of contradictions and I ignore him
friends I'm chasing down dreams but it
seems like you ain't as supportive as
you've seen
Amy don't act like you're all that
you're just jealous of my progress so
now you attack I'm grinding hard
building my Empire and you can and if
you can't keep up step aside don't come
conspire
you say I left you hanging like I don't
care but it's my ambition that got me
where I am that's rare
if you answer my back you'd be cheering
me on instead of writing dishes claiming
our bombs are gone
pointing fingers blame on me but look in
the mirror maybe and maybe you'll see
the real issue is here is not my grind
it's the Envy in your heart and that's
need you got to find
oh [__] dude
baby don't act like you're all that
you're just jealous of my progress and
now you attack I'm grinding hard
building my Empire and if you can't keep
up step aside but don't conspire
yeah you know what it is huh I'm working
hard trying to make it big but you're
too busy hating on my gig if you were a
real friend you'd be by my side not
trying to tear me down with your weak
Rhymes it's a way B listen up I'll make
it clear
I'm keep chasing my dreams with the
route your cheer you can come along or
stay in your way but I won't let your
bitterness dictate my day
[Music]
pretty hard yeah it's like a modern day
Tupac
oh maybe I should do rewrite it but like
Tupac [__] is doing it
that's enough rewrite it but as if Tupac
is
as if Tupac wrote it I mean you're going
to Denice that mm-hmm UAB you coming at
me with another ditch it's talk on the
mic let me tell you this no no I'm
forgetting friends I'm just chasing my
fate it's about the dream homie no time
for hate that didn't sound like Tupac it
there are some words that are kind of
creepy I'll spot on really hey B don't
get that Twisted player it ain't about
neglect it's about climbing higher I'm
on my grind creating my legacy don't
hate the game man it's just my destiny I
think you gotta and Warren yeah well
pocket like Legacy like Legacy right
right right
don't get the Twister player oh my God
now I'm about to hit the button create
my legacy don't hate the game man it's
just like just to leave I'm about to hit
the button right right
all right we've had enough of this
don't hit the button
you're getting tomatoes in the chat
please
that [__] goes hard as hell [__]
you'll love that don't even front
all right where were we we've done zero
of the doc actually we should probably
talk about
the main Stories We were talking about
Gwyneth you want to do that
I thought we just did that's it let's
see so let's talk about no we have Clips
the clips are really good okay
let's watch it
so this guy Sanderson he's a retired
optometrist okay and he's suing her
um
there's a lots of great clips from him
being examined by her attorneys here's
one
this man really looks like a plantation
owner
like this dude definitely owned slaves
no yeah he was like extra white Colonel
Sanders basically extra white Esco
crispy
all different flavors all different
flavors just remember everything was
great and then
I heard something I've never heard of
the ski resort and that was a blood
curdling scream
just I can't do it
you never heard a scream
I just remember ski resort nobody ever
gets hurt there and people get hurt
they're routinely that place is
dangerous than [__] that's what I was
joking about this whole thing because
it's like
if you've ever been to a ski resort it's
just people are just dying everywhere
they're like tumbling they're falling
stop there's a cliff side Matt it's
chaos I've never been but I've seen
Housewives
try it this key
no also I don't know if you know this
detail but this
this life-changing crash happened on the
bunny slope
that's like the training slope or
children's ski where it's not too Steep
and it's really small so you can learn
that's where this all happened so isn't
that like where you're supposed to fall
yep
pretty much this sounds so stupid here
is uh
do you recall saying Jesus Christ what
so loud
it's like every courtroom
like the great sound system it's a jet
engine or it's like whisper quieting
every recording of a trial you agreed
that saying I'm famous
was a crazy thing to say
agree absolutely it's not me it's I'm
come by into that but it was you right
just to be clear when you say it wasn't
me it it was in fact you it's the other
personality that's inhabiting my body
right now after the crash he texted did
that other personality the one that's
suing her dude he's right he's
unraveling so what what's the background
on that one Olivia so after the crash he
texted one of his daughters I'm famous
and then attached the article
he's like okay what's up with this dude
yeah it's my other personality dude
cause brain damage that caused him to
have like a split person he actually
said are you serious yeah yeah oh that's
what he's talking about so desperate for
so long gosh brother oh my God
wow
so so I if I was the attorney I would
follow us so which one of the
personalities was in the Collision you
know was it you or the other one yeah
which one is suing us at this moment
uh gwyneth's attorney presented to the
court
um
her team wanted to bring in treats for
the bailiff is that right that's a bit
much that's a lot of order
um
this
private security for my client wanted to
uh bring in
treats for the bailiffs for how helpful
they've been so I wanted to do that he
was so embarrassed to ask that yeah
Gwyneth is like you've got to ask if we
can bring in treats we got goop uh anal
beads we got lotion we got goop
vibrators
but
he he took so long to spit it out that
was incredible and he's like oh God
Jesus Christ
[__]
are you your honor have you heard about
the glow stick would you like one for
your face we have a Yoni egg pretty
white your owner how's your sexual
health with your wife does it need
Improvement well we got treats for her
may I ask your honor have you ever heard
of dragon pills
uh bring in
treats for the bailiffs for how helpful
they've been I don't want to do that
transparently and see if there were any
objections
okay there's an objection okay objection
of course there is but it's kind of a
dub because they're like yeah I want
traits and then their Lord's like
objection like oh we don't get treated
nice play there
let them know thank you but but no thank
you you know he was like please they're
not he's like please don't make me do
this
louder
okay if the parties decide to do that
later that's fine too
yeah just do it later what is this
[__] what is this kindergarten you're
bringing treats just give it to the
person later that's so weird you you got
goodie bags for all the uh jurors
it hasn't been done
I know it should have asked us first we
can talk about it but just running on us
now what'd you find out about the jury
now they're fighting about the goodies
ready to go okay
um
um eye level [__] going on during work
millions of dollars and lots of time
being spent in court
foreign there was a tangent in court
where they discussed the word anal
has an anal retentive this is anal sex
this is fascinating interesting as what
well I didn't make it up uh came from so
this is um his
this is
his daughter
he's questioning one of sanderson's
about the use of the word anal
okay yeah well I didn't make it up
came from somewhere okay anal retentive
has nothing to do with our bottoms is
that true
just to make sure we're talking about
the same thing I it's got the word anal
in it I know what are they talking about
anal retentive means like you're
obsessed about details right yes but is
it related to anal
uh like the butthole I was really like
anal retentive oh like when somebody
says they're anal yeah yeah that's what
it means yes I don't think it's related
to you know what I think it actually is
is it the etymology of it it's because
yeah it comes from Freud's psychoanal
analysis and he had like the anal stage
oral stage like development and uh
all of this is like outdated
psychological stuff but the I think the
turn of phrase does originate from that
so uh it's crazy
bless you
I'm okay oh man
thank you
is that the definition
I'll tell you what let's I think it's
obsessive sort of that's how I
understand it but
I don't know what that means but I am
obsessed with anal
y just kidding
I'm neutral on it
I hope you get ass cancer and die you
son of a [__] all right
all right
not that serious man
um
here's clips of him talking about how he
has multiple personalities this is
recall saying that you agreed that
saying I'm famous
was a crazy thing to say this is the
same one we just watched in it
maybe it's longer a little bit longer
yeah but you're talking about the one
that was a few videos back yeah agree
absolutely it's not me it's fun
don't buy into that but it was you right
when you say it with me
it's the same one yeah
uh this one is awesome he says he's this
is my favorite considering he's an
optometrist here he is getting grilled
now you're you're right eye
has problems right a little bit yeah not
a little bit yes a little bit blind no
you told three of your providers at the
VA I'm blind on my right eye I use the
word Lucy you used it and you're an
optometrist
this guy
if you don't know what that means who
does brother I love that oh [__]
that's awesome
that was my favorite compilation Eclipse
below here oh this is um
this is the compilation it's just a time
stamp
oh what here I'll send him sorry I don't
know that happened can we see her there
that was from the day before but we can
bring them back for you if you want
the state of Texas just gifted um
50 Subs the state of Texas yeah the
whole damn state
how do I just see five yeah 50 subs
thank you so
nice to see you
um
that's not the right link yeah I'm
looking for it right now okay
yes so uh here's his daughter by the way
again on stage and we'll watch some some
Gwyneth clips for you why is his
daughter on stage I guess they're
winning because he was texting him about
how he's famous and [__] okay okay this
one is really weird
this is a family of goons man I'll tell
you what boy
are you staying with your dad literally
like last night tonight
he is running at the rbo yes and I am
staying with him
he's got great reviews five star reviews
okay it's way too loud
turn it down got a crazy sound system
there
once I pause it I can't are you saying
he personally or the place you're
renting
um I just I'm trying to be funny and
it's not coming across something funny
I'm staying with my dad he's letting me
stay there no problem you are under oh
you are under oh this is he's doing
stick right now and it's horrible
horrible the the joke that's like the
family joke wait it gets worse it gets
more Awkward
[Music]
okay all right the GoPro email we're
getting sick of what looking at it so
I'm not gonna follow that you're right
so
but uh
your understanding after talking to your
dad can I just make it clear that that
whole VRBO thing five star reviews that
was all just a joke
I'm making clear for the record that
that's not happening and I apologize
okay wow humor you are one weird lady
yeah
as a family of strange people right
there
who tries to be funny in this kind of
situation and tell a joke like it's like
a dad joke
especially that one dude yeah that was a
rough one My Darkest fears are making
are you staying with your dad in a legal
situation and she's like yeah he's
renting me he's playing he's got five
star hotel she seemed dead serious
I'll tell you what uh he owned he runs
in VRBO
he is letting you know his favorite
daughter because he's only got one
daughter you know all these like stupid
Family jokes
bad [__] yeah he's playing the classics
so here is um one of the goofball
families attorneys now I suspect what
happened is these attorneys took the
case on contingency they thought they
were going to get a big payday from
Gwyneth then once you get committed to a
client you can't leave them it's illegal
they can get in trouble with the bar
association so they're kind of forced
into this situation
uh and well listen to the credentials he
is constantly putting out here how can
you diagnose it
Dr has done it
through your report
again I'm a simple country lawyer but I
can read it's a very short question I
can't read later
okay sometimes just a simple country
lawyer not for sure don't say simple one
more time this man really thinks he's
like Attica Atticus fin she's in like uh
maybe just a simple country lawyer but I
know what's right is right I got a
simple brain I don't know me much about
the big cities but I know right from
right
[Music]
it's like the very basic version of the
brain it's so funny real simple I tell
you what man
I might be a country Lord but I can read
what does this say right here
third percentile
now I'm just a simple country lawyer
a little bit intimidated I think he's
he's actually I feel like in the movies
they would say that as a way yeah
posturing themselves they're just in
like parodies of [__] like I feel
like Foghorn leghorns said that in like
a Looney Tunes you know what I mean yeah
well usually you would say it as like uh
as a way to flex on someone I'm nothing
special but this is obvious to even me
but he's actually using it as a
disclaimer yeah
this is an authentic introduction I want
to preface this by saying I'm not very
good at my job
so please forgive me if this makes no
sense I just got a smooth brain my brain
is smooth
you remember Phil Hartman there was an
SNL sketch where he was a thought out um
uh caveman and became a lawyer caveman
lawyer I believe was the name of the
sketch and he would do that whole shtick
I'm just a simple okay I'm just a
caveman attorney that's funny
I just looked him up too and he's from
Salt Lake City he's a Salt Lake City
Country I guess that's not the country
yeah exactly
I mean they're weird there don't get me
wrong fairly Rural and Salt Lake City
the city that's the city though
traditionally
and then I watched Salt Lake City
those are City Slickers they ain't no
country girls gotcha by the way I think
this is what she was handing out Milk
Bone treats
or the bailiffs the bailiff treats
cleans teeth and freshens the breath we
need it
not wanting to go out and do things
it's a simple country lawyer okay I'm
gonna try that question again
or object I'm just a country boy
you like that he's so [__] out of his
death
basically quitting
but he's just a simple country lawyer
say that at the same time they're just
like they're all cheating
to his face now I might be dumb
so excuse me for this I barely passed
the bar I'm very old
thank you Texas for another 15 gift to
the state of Texas wow ladies and
gentlemen they're actually generous they
also said that it's uh coming from the
tax dollars of the good people of Texas
thank you very much I like that they're
giving back they taken off certainly so
it's nice to get it back
um
let's see Sanders goop page for more
clips
a good page for more Clips there's any
good ones here
uh there's a couple good ones but
there's the update today there's a good
clip right here at the end
now you're you're right eye
has problems right now it's so good it's
so good yeah this is a good way to end
it this this one that maybe got down
here maybe he's got a good one for us
this was her uh
twisting the knife she won and she just
left immediately and she's like everyone
remain seated well the parties leave I'm
gonna make a quick [__] I got [__] to
do yeah have a good night
apparently she whispered in his ear
take care or something yeah she said
take care you couldn't hear it so I just
put that sound bite in there have a good
night okay she just bossed her way out
apparently she said my next candle will
smell like your corpse
my favorite one
what a dumbass bro you're an idiot you
just got a big slap by Gwyneth Paltrow
goop he just gooped all over
got gooped on idiot
yeah so jury sided with her
deciding that the skiing accident was
not her fault in fact love it granted
her uh legal fees of a million dollars
there you go
ouch
smell you later dum dum Hey Kevin I hope
you're watching
you already owe me 60k you're racking up
bills I gotta go to the bathroom
all right
so you guys do whatever you want really
I'll be back
I'm wondering if I should go to is this
like
we're gonna break the break the bathroom
bathroom did a number one or a number
two
doesn't know how he doesn't know when he
goes in the bathroom you [__] know
hey we never talked about you clogging
the toilet again hey clogged in left
he's all you guys deal with it he left
a giant [__] dookie
in one of the toilets and he was like I
got somewhere to be I gotta go he's like
you guys worry about it I can't deal
with them
yeah I think the most offensive part is
that the door was left open yep I
believe that was intended to air it out
but it just aired it out into the studio
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh God I was standing next to Ian I was
all the way by the fridge and I'm like
Ian did you [__] [__] your pants bro
what the [__] is that smell and then I
followed it and I realized that the door
was open so I had some distance on it's
pretty impressive
I don't know if impressive's the right
word for it I mean it had some range I
like that yeah I guess maybe like puked
man
from the stench of it I did cough
exactly a little bit Yeah gag that's
what I was looking for
we should know we should mention that I
wasn't in a hurry for alfredo or no
Shredder Shredder that's true Shredder
yeah
and also to his credit
I offered to take care of it he said no
no he wants to take care of himself so
did he take care of it was it I didn't
even check did you offer to take care of
him yes but I used to work at a doctor's
office there's some [__] up [__] man
old people used to drop their phones in
the toilet and I had to [__] dig them
out
[Music]
well yeah with your gag reflex you gag
all the time I could deal with that kind
of [__] I just can't deal with like
nasty foods and [__] like that you can
sift through [__] but you can't deal
with nasty Foods
I'd rather did you shift I'd rather did
you go handsome [__] we are different
we're so [__] wait taking like a shot
of ranch to be honest we are different
people you actually went in there like
with your hand in the poop I would put
gloves you know you know I see your
mindset on that one maybe yeah because I
think I'd rather touch [__] than like
eat Greek yogurt or something like oh my
god really oh without a doubt I'd rather
eat this [__] that is okay bro I'll make
you a poop snowman [__] with a poop
Play-Doh snowman before I [__] who
played them do a a shot of ranch
what
I get them I get the mindset I totally
get the mindset thank you
yeah
sorry he was back
maybe you don't want Branch riveting
conversation oh yeah no I don't like
Ryan is it because it's like garlic
forward I know you hate part of it yeah
I have a question
this office
um
you have so much candy here
what is going on in this office
a lot of it gets bought to do stuff on
the show and then people send us some
and really I don't know it like
it's a good point there is a lot of
candy over there we just got a bunch
just like been accumulating we just got
a bunch of French candy recently right
somebody right exactly yeah like a huge
box of uh
French money
yeah shout out uh who that was what was
their name
reviews yeah
so
that's part of it
um but
I mean is there a problem
the candy yeah
it just kind of looks like
somebody who's really high on weight is
having like that groceries
Dan you're getting weed
hell yeah
oh yeah right I noticed that too when I
was in America
it's like I can't stop myself either if
there's candy I'll eat it right but when
I'm alone I never buy candy for myself
but I mean it's probably not great for
Ethan density is going to get handy and
he's coming back with chips this is this
is
excited you wanted the salty
and then he came
the toilet about it at least we got a
got an answer to what Ethan was gonna do
right we got our answer probably
probably safe to assume by now he
doesn't do number two it's a number
three
all right
I feel like if you don't know what's
gonna happen you know what's gonna
happen right that makes sense that is
exactly it yeah
it's like the bachelor when at the last
three and they're going to fantasy suite
it's like you know he tells everybody
they don't know yet they know yeah
that's crazy to not know exactly like I
know in this most recent finale he's
like I don't know where I'm going to be
tomorrow I'm like what do you not know
so obvious who he was gonna pick yeah it
was so obvious and he still chose to
sleep with that or girl before
That's How The Show Goes though
it does
extra socks
though I stopped watching it so boring I
stopped watching halfway through the
season yeah I was so behind I watched
this video I didn't even know uh one of
the girls names it was like
at this point
are you watching farmer finds a wife no
I'm watching Breaking Bad For the First
Time wow
yeah I've never started it and I'm
obsessed with it it's all I want to
watch
yeah you can't keep getting away with it
Dan's just snacking
the real two zone right here
[Music]
sick stuff
Zach Lewis live at the Roxy folks I was
waiting for this
May 13th May 13th just throwing that out
there last La show last La show
I got something I want to plug if you're
uh in Chicago or the Chicago area
um and you're going to uh c2e2 this
weekend my girlfriend Ali will be there
she's got a booth so um
go buy everything from now in Chicago
c2e2 it's a great place gonna go see
alley I'm gonna watch some anime and get
going to the anime convention that's
right John Wayne Gacy he's got a pool
cleaning service
nice
we love it
what you guys got planned this weekend
anything fun us
um well it's Passover so we're doing
that with the family at our house nice
so
that's a little bit scary it's like
we're gonna have like 15 people or
something like that
do you guys have that many every year
this time we have more actually because
we also invited a friend and my brother
from New York is out here oh sweet
girlfriend so
it's a little bit more than usual
Passover is Wednesday right is that when
like the official holidays I think so I
think we're not doing it on the actual
day
[Music]
later that's smart
I hope you have a beautiful time with
the big family there thank you me too
thank you sounds fun and besides that
every weekend for us is just survival
it's just like it's us on the boys
like who's gonna get to sleep at night
we take turns if one of us was up late
then the other one sleeps and we take
turns and
it's just survival the only way I can
describe it
but they're so cute they are so cute
they're ridiculously cute I suppose that
helps doesn't it it does help
who's more trouble during the night
Bruce really
Theodore used to go to sleep 6 30 until
6 30. it's crazy 12 hours of sleep
nothing we would go and check on him to
make sure he's breathing
nothing and then Bruce is like if he
sleeps three hours without noise you're
lucky
um we've actually got to a point now
where I have to take birth with me to
bed and Ethan has to sleep in another
bed because when Ethan comes in the
middle of the night and he's on his
phone and he's watching stuff Bruce
wakes up and then I wake up and then
we're all up all night
so we figured out that if eaten is not
there
Bruce is sleeping better
but like that's just yeah just gotta do
whatever works
[Music]
the routine it's tough because we I was
so proud with Theodore we were able to
like get him to sleep in his bed and we
never did the co-sleep thing
but I don't know wait boys it's just not
like that
so
but
they're so different and it's so funny
like during the day Bruce is also
becoming more trouble
than Theodore sometimes which is very
crazy
like he's he's starting to walk he's not
he's not fully walking yet but he can do
like six steps but he's climbing on
everything he's the climber and if
you're not looking for one second he's
on the table
crazy
talented really yeah all the way on on
the table yeah he already knows where's
the candy in our pantry
I don't know how
he is Ethan's son I've been into college
um
the other day I saw Theodore
we have like those uh safety things on
the electric
Outlets
and we have a shredder in my office and
it's unplugged
just for safety so Theodore took out the
safety thing from the plug then plugged
in the shredder and started shredding
our mail
oh all by himself oh
that's like the ultimately
it's like what is going on it's not even
four yet I just want to help he's all
business
and now they're teaming up on the like
Theodore thinks it's so funny is like
we're doing trouble and they're together
like if Bruce like accidentally pours
water on the like it happened last night
Bruce spilled water on the table in the
living room and he starts playing with
it like this
and then Teddy's just cracking up
laughing and he's like yes go Bruce go
Bruce that's okay
God
there's before you get back uh there's a
ten dollar donation from Sam Fuller or
10 pound donation who's saying that they
are pitching to score their biggest
movie yet Stars Al Pacino in it wish me
luck good luck that's awesome as long as
he's not selling Dunkin Donuts I'm cool
yeah
um Don Cachino the dunkaccino yeah okay
first of all what did you say about me
clogging toilets because I feel like I
need to defend myself
what just happened today how did it go
fine okay
no fog good good we said that you
clogged the toilet and then you had
somewhere important to be for Shredder
and so you didn't have time to deal with
it and so you left with the door open to
air it out which made me like that
dude I close the door and stacked like a
whole bunch of [__] in front of it who
says I open left it open this man said
it was you're a liar it was open it was
you were somebody walking bro
Ian wasn't not open yesterday
I didn't go look but I didn't see you
said oh it stinks why are you lying
maybe someone else tried to go in there
yeah remember I stacked a bunch of [__]
in front I closed the door I said guys I
remember you doing that last time I
don't I did not witness you stacked
things in front of the door this time
you said but I also didn't see that it
was open so that was the lid this is
between you and a B I never saw it I
don't have nothing to do with Debbie
remember you said at least
listen to me I didn't see the listen
you said go close to the lid remember
that I said yeah don't let it close the
lid so I went I moved everything out of
the way
I closed the lid right close the door
and put everything back
okay I'm not saying I just believe you
I'm just reporting what's been reported
to me okay well he's lying
I left early yesterday to take Ali to
the airport and so I did not witness the
the smell and the first thing I did when
I came back I went in there the poop had
gone down
I cleaned it with the brush oh you did
okay because I first walked in there and
I was like
walking right back out because it was
down there was no poop in there but it
looked like
there were some skid marks this morning
yeah yeah and working how far I was I
told you not to I said I'll clean it
when I get back
how could how can I clean skid marks if
I'm not here I thought you were
referring to you came back yesterday no
no when I got here okay I took the brush
I cleaned out the [__]
what can I do I I what could I have done
I had to leave yeah I agree you're not
in the wrong here but then now Amy's
lying on me for some reason that's some
silly [__] I'm back did you go back did
you go back to check it after like after
the show we were hanging out for a while
didn't you go back in there for
something I forget what it was to close
the lid yeah okay you said that and then
he said he re-stacked okay well yeah
that's what I'm saying I it may have
been someone else they went in there and
just left it I didn't say it was
specifically you but did he what did he
say then I mean I may have at the point
at the said all he said was that the
door was open and it stunk up the studio
that's not true
is it was anyone else here for this for
the stunk for the stank how was it it
did I did yeah that's [__] we have
three people one stank dude is Stanky
whatever I closed the [__] door it
was smeary this morning how can we fix
your poop schedule because for me I
always go in the morning before I leave
the house I don't have a schedule does
it just hit you at a random time because
on leftovers as soon as the show started
yeah [__] I gotta [__] yes it just hits
me at random times of the day
could be morning could be afternoon
could be night
that's crazy and it is what it is I
guess tough life
what strikes me as a bit weird is how
yeah I think you need to poop etiquette
like flushing etiquette do you need to
poop a little and then flash flash the
poop yeah he's right there's no courtesy
you don't know what you're talking no
flash throughout it's there's no
flushing throughout it's not like that
there's courtesy flushes no he's trying
to say that it's continuous yeah one
contiguous log there's no moment to
flush and I'm not standing up I'm not
that water's not special your ass and
I'm definitely not standing up because
it's not it's not ready to be standing
then the toilet is going to clock
you're not ready to do that it's going
to clock five I close the door there's
two bathrooms here there's not that many
people here I closed the door I will say
there's also two more downstairs yeah
there's like a technically there's four
bathrooms there's two bathrooms
downstairs and there's like nobody there
okay
spare Me Maybe
well somehow we don't get trouble like
that at home so because yeah no the
toilets are more powerful I admit I
don't know for whatever reason I've been
dropping some big ass monsters here
well I'm sure you do the same at home
it's a rare kind of thing do we need to
get you a massive toilet
no like you said I never clogged the
woods at home these ones are just do
they make like oversized does the size
of the toilet matter no it's your real
huge well nobody no size matter guys
some toilets have a stronger flush I
don't know that
uh I'm trying to see if there's oh this
looks interesting
I don't need a strong flushing uh toilet
I mean I do but because that's dangerous
too you know yeah like when uh Larry has
the stronger pee on curb it splashes
back at you you don't well you don't
want to mess with that no good toilets
to flush hard they flush it down down
not out
like for example our toilets at home I
could be on the bowl blush and it
doesn't Splash my ass at all right
now here I wouldn't do that because
you're gonna get [__] water on your ass
and if I stand up my jeeps are gonna
spread smash like a [__] peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
[Laughter]
have we considered maybe it's not
the poop itself like are you putting
whites on there no that's right so how
are you wiping around
guys you don't you really yeah I'm just
there's a lot of assets that use those
bathrooms all day I do there are wet
wipes in there there are specifically in
that bathroom that's the only one he
doesn't use wet wipes guys no of course
not we don't guys listen we banned those
it clogs before the paper even hits the
gray that's not possible dude I'm
telling me I think I think you're using
too many wipes Zach why are you calling
me a [__] liar because I think you're
lying anything when do I lie about
anything you know what I'm going back on
this one you're going against the family
maybe you're just saying that because
you [__] got caught lying about and
now you're trying to like stay faced I
literally said I would clean your [__]
this is I don't care I told you no I
know you told me no okay
I don't want you to clean my shoes I
know you do I know so why do you say
that I'm saying because to that extent
I'm willing to try to help but I'm being
how are you helping you are listen he
gave perfectly plausible explanations
for why he didn't say you left the door
open but then when you were talking
about it you said you left the door open
and to let it air out right there was an
accusation that's what you said and if
that's the information that gave you
that was that is a little bit suspicious
that was convenient you don't get to
hide behind this oh I said I clean your
[__] out of the toilet that's I'm not I
said no okay I know you said
and I also use that to do one at a time
this is my show you guys listen I talk
why are you getting kind of defensive
there Ethan Zach
back you're going against the Fairly I
cannot believe but I'm rich Witnesses
I'm just I Zach quiet
Yes master
I just want to give a quick shout out to
all the foot soldiers out there that are
sitting down for breakfast lunch or
dinner
quiet all right here we go I forget what
I was gonna say
listen Zach
Abu saying oh it's gonna wipe your [__]
you came here and you lied on my name
even that point we're still defending
you guys
wipe my shoes
I know you don't sound like a saint
because you had 11 you were in the
bathroom people or you come out here and
embarrass me when I'm not even here to
defend myself okay watch it back later
watch my back later watch it back later
I thought you said watch your back later
watch your back
this man told me watch my back like I
said I'm just gonna bring I'm gonna just
find a whiteboard I'm bringing a white
board I'll just write on it no that's
for the record I don't not support that
threat
watch your basketball back later I swear
and Zach shame on you bro why would I
lie about the amount why would I lie
about it well you can explain about
everything and I come here and I'm lying
about the how the toilet clogged yeah
you accuse me of that you haven't
explained how you wiped your ass with
toilet paper
okay I'm telling you it clogged before
the paper even hit the drain bro it was
a massive bio how do you know that
though how many because the [__] didn't
even go down there was so much of it is
it possible
and now y'all [__] want the stupid
ass details because you call me a liar
it's a big [__] pile of [__] and it
wouldn't go down the drain bro I'm
saying it could be a combo the paper did
it the poop hadn't gone down the paper
was above the [__] bro I've seen corked
yeah instantly yes
[__] up then and I've sat in there it
should be able to do its work yeah I
think so by the way maybe there's a
toilet paper I thought of so much more
than of you than using toilet paper as
opposed to what the wipes are bad
did you use the bidet no I don't use
communal bid days it's weird wash your
back dude wait so who does use those
wipes that are in there is that you Zach
no I use a bidet yeah why are they there
okay it's Zach no he's the bidet hmm
I use wipes at home I [__] you know [__]
it but uh yeah [__] the landlord yeah
listen I have respect I respect you guys
enough to you know not leave a toilet
clogged no it's like mortar bro it's
like straight up mortar like a whole
pound of it and so it doesn't the tissue
doesn't even get a chance to go down the
drain
and I've stood there in the bathroom I
call it the act of God because it's not
like solid it's only a matter of time
before it weakens and goes down and I
keep Flushing to keep the pressure on it
and when God acts to relieve that on his
own without me intervening I watched the
toilet paper goes down with no problem
so this dump was an act of God no the
flushing was an act of God okay now I
have a question or a suggestion what if
you like [__] on the edge so he doesn't
really like clog it forward it's a
dangerous game I think that's bad
that's it
this is the solution dude not on the
edge
often worse because you want it in your
water have you ever heard the expression
[__] rolls downhill yeah it will it will
it will spread out
a slight bit of water and you can flush
flush I hate those because lately
Theodore has massive shits and he's [__]
kind of hits on the side of the ball
because he's not big enough you know
yeah
it's disgusting those are those are
terrible I I do not recommend it
I asked chat gbt I said should I be
concerned if I have giant poops okay
okay I'm not a doctor but I can provide
some general information if you're
experiencing unusually large bowel
movements it can be due to a variety of
factors including diet hydration
exercise habits however you're
experiencing pain no blood no
significant changes in bowel habits I
mean
I wouldn't say that or other concerning
symptoms important to consult with the
doctor no just massive shits I'll say
nope nope no blood or pain just
I I don't think you're asking the right
question by phrasing it as being massive
it's when you describe it as being like
mortar okay it sounds like it's way too
[__] you're [__] bricks no it's
not bricks it's like it's like liquid
concrete sure right it's like it's like
a putty material my my poop is like um
it's not really hard though it comes out
no problem it's like it's Clay I feel
like if it were some other the suction
of the toilet would just suck it down
anyways like it does have a lot of stuff
well maybe you need stool softener
no it's soft that's what I'm saying it's
soft have you felt it have you felt yeah
I haven't felt it I mean I felt it
coming out of my butt but it's not like
constipated you know
I do think that the bathroom on the left
side has less of a powerful flush than
the one on the right so maybe that's the
problem I think the toilet is the
problem seriously yeah thank you
supports me around here I live with you
I if it wasn't a problem at home I would
have known that the problem is you wait
I just I just want to test something
next time you take a [__] can you do it
in the other bathroom
but I think you're less likely to clog
the right than the left no I'll tell you
what's happening I don't know why
but sometimes
for whatever reasons like I had pizza or
something then the poop comes out like a
lot of it probably because I'm not
digesting a lot of that garbage like my
body doesn't want it and it's just like
a huge pile of [__] like a lot you're
selling yourself short right now
when do you eat pizza well I did the
other day and then it happened and I
clogged the toilet I'm just using okay
it happens sometimes I'll leave you
gonna eat it regularly I see what you
eat every evening no I know it doesn't
happen all the time I'm just saying
these
these clogging shits happen usually
because of something I did or something
I ate no those are happening way more
than you eating pizza
right but it could be that I had like a
gnarly like Mexican feast with lots of
salsa or something and it's just all
coming out of me is what I mean
there's a lot coming out of me and I
promise you guys like I swear to you
right now like let me don't because now
this became like a big deal let me get
up paint
like I need to you guys really [__]
put me in this position
what do you call them well we gotta find
a solution because we can't keep we
can't keep doing well that one went down
that one was fine after 24 hours
no no I just took the time it went down
oh that one right yeah okay fair enough
I mean usually that's the only time I
had ever had to leave it there you know
God forbid do you have um
IBS
I mean I don't know maybe
nothing to do about it though right no
it's not it's like oh yeah
so yeah your shit's [__] up there's
nothing you can do about it though happy
[__] I don't think I have IBS it's
not that bad
how do I do um drawing uh drawing a
website I just need something to draw on
so I can show you guys
here sketchpad dot IO there you go
okay okay all right so let me see okay
I'm not gonna make it gross I just want
to show you guys
so here is let's say the bull okay what
is poop knife everybody keeps typing
that poop knife that's not a thing don't
say that
what is it it's a whole urban legend
thing from oh it comes out of the toilet
somebody assassinates you no no I think
it I think it was it all originated from
somebody on Reddit explaining how they
discovered that their family was the
only one with a poop knife they thought
everybody had one
and it was basically a Knife by the
toilet for when your [__] is super huge
you'd use it oh my God stick it in there
and break it that's what if I had that
there'd be no problem I don't know if it
was a real story or if it was somebody I
could see that being a real thing but
yeah I think that's the origin of it
okay so so here's the bow okay
this is the bull the seat is here I'm
just I'm just showing you the bowl now
hit that drain let's say is about you
know
somebody said it's real my friend has
one
they sell gag ones stop it I mean how
big would you say the hole is it's like
I don't know this big right
not enormous
goes in that is small that's a small
hole was that a sound I think it's
pretty small yeah it's pretty small okay
so let's say
like this big I don't know
better well the thing is it it goes in
yeah let's just say this is the hole
okay
so here's what's happening it's filling
up the hole all the way okay and then
it's making a huge amount outside the
hole this big yeah I'm telling you and
it's going up high it's filling all this
the hole is full and it's making a mound
this big yeah it's like stuffed and so
when you flush it there's almost no like
you could use the fill tool to uh paint
and pick Brown and no I'm not I don't
want to gross people out too much
there's just and then so the and Zach
the toilet paper is all here right
why would you put it on the top
it's it's all dude what do you want from
me well there's there's a sign to it but
okay proceed what's the science proceed
what's the science Zach there's a
science to it what's the science well
why would you put the toilet paper I
just drop it in the toilet wherever it
falls there you lift your balls and you
go from back to front right yeah right
yeah right okay so why would you
let it towards the front wouldn't it be
more on the back or Center where you
drop the toilet paper what
okay I can't believe it
when you wipe you look at it right yeah
usually so that explains it yeah but why
would you
I I wipe my ass and then I put it down
in the bowl okay we're not but it could
be anywhere okay fine here it's all over
the [__] place okay you don't have to
get mad don't have to get mad please
proceed well you guys are trying to
frame me as some [__] I didn't I I
seriously okay I just
maybe
threatened you
I know that was not cool
I got nothing to say oh my God nothing
to do with this
[Music]
show you but you think I left the door
opening no if you're saying you didn't
then you didn't I believe you didn't but
it was open
but I'm not saying it was you
there are a lot of people confused by
the back to front situation oh we've
been over it
we can make a lore video on yeah
we don't need to have that conversation
again some people don't believe you guys
have to scoop your balls we've talked
about this there was a huge topical
conversation yeah in previous years but
we used to summarize some people wipe
from the front me and others there are
others like me out there we took a poll
that was like 35 40 I think 40 maybe
yeah it was like 60 40 something like
that yeah and so I would lift my balls
and scoop
and then the other people go somewhere
which I don't find possible I can't
swipe from the back it doesn't make
sense there's a highlight on it you guys
it does not make sense at all and this
only applies to men as far as I know
because women really shouldn't do that
right yeah but you're not well you're
you're not you know how to knock that
[__] in your vagina no
that's not it's like I don't get [__]
under my balls
how do you know
no I guess how do you know I just I've
never felt like I've wiped up my ball
sack
kind of hard to look down there isn't it
but I guess there's the stakes are not
as high for me
as free as for ladies
you know what I mean
the stakes are lower yeah a lot of
people are just learning about the front
uh uh we can do a poll this goes to show
how much uh our audience has evolved
over there yeah because that was such a
major topic there's probably about
25 hours of H3 podcast footage debating
this over the course of many and we we
used to ask every guest yeah it was a
common guest oh that is still a good
question I forgot about it no no we've
moved on
we've resolved it I mean we get it Bert
is actually a front wiper we learned
yeah so we bonded over that yeah
well we have a lot more women so I'm
assuming there's not going to be as many
front wipers as before but let's do a
poll I'm curious now can we do no I'm a
woman yes I'm a woman and two da9 is a
cancer-free king thank you state of
Texas
I do believe that I've met women who
have confessed to wiping from the front
really yeah I mean they're out there you
know they're out there I cannot imagine
so front to put Clarity means going
under the legs this way back of course
is like that behind the back I'm front
to back wait
you're back to front you're back to
front oh so I'm confused on my own bad
bad pole event
you're the one who does it like that I
voted for the wrong one oh wait front to
back yeah wait it is that's a bad pull
yeah you need to say wipe from the front
or wipe from the back okay
wipe from the front wait can we add
women in the back like
women wipe from front when one white
from back let's do one for just for the
man why okay so just we can do both plus
four
oh good idea okay and then it just goes
out to the lady they're at a third
option that you're that you're a man or
whatever n a not applicable pull
so front means you go from the front
back means you go from the back yes
this is for the ladies only being the
right way wait I thought you wanted me
to do it being the wrong way this is for
the ladies wiping is optional okay I'll
just do I'll do just okay just the
ladies front or back third option for n
a if being a lady wiping does not apply
to you wiping is optional
stop that
foreign
a because you know I'm not
okay I'm having a vagina
dude okay at first that was really close
thirty percent thirty percent wipe from
the front whoa
33 it's going up what
yo that's crazy some people say both
this is for pooping this is for pooping
not peeing
because it doesn't matter if you wipe
I think this one is even more confusing
because from the front is from the the
first one was way better explained it
back from front from the front and this
one is confused you came up with Ethan
yeah
right in front or back let me let me all
right
the entire history has been fronted
we're talking about wearing so no balls
describing what I
how I do it and how even does it so do
you wipe like this yes absolutely
weren't you just making fun of me no no
you guys have talked about Zach's always
been on your side good man as a matter
of fact a little preview for the Zach
lore video which is on its way uh where
we've we've completed the uh assembly
and collecting all the clips so I would
say probably uh next weekend like by the
end of next week where we will be
launching that Lord very exciting but
anyways this one is a jug or not it's a
juggernaut and Zach's first appearance
on the podcast was him chiming in that
he wipes like you've been his supporters
day one brother that's why we bonded so
yeah that's right he instantly became
the gold something about the Jewish
wiping you know disconnect
she want to do another poll because
according to this 36 percent are wiping
oh I don't think this says yeah 48 wipe
like all of the back front and this is
for the ladies no no yeah 48 from the
back which means that they bring It
Forward
you come from here
okay the front means you come from here
I see you're talking about like the
scooting action yeah
so you guys are thinking of in a
different way you're talking about so
which direction in your life because I
was thinking you go from the back or the
front you're talking about hand
placement yeah I wasn't talking about
which way you scoop
I see so there is confusion here
we have confusion
yeah this is a bad poll then
don't look at me you created it
yeah I thought this was the way but I
see a lot of confusions
confusion happening in the comments too
[Music]
got it
I guess we'll move on
anyways I'm sorry guys I I I literally I
don't know what to do because I clogged
it and I literally had to go to the
specialist for Shredder I didn't have an
option
I wasn't even attending the poop but I I
like hit me
and I was wrong there was no intention
you know no hard feelings
and I do not expect anyone to go clean
my [__] for crazy I guess no don't even
ask me that
you would never
never
I think you're in the right here
definitely I'm in the right good thing
having said that according to a b watch
your back
I did here watch my back maybe you
should grab that I want to hear it
he said watch your back later
I said watch it back later that makes
more sense yeah I still think you should
because I was like why are you
threatening me bro it's not that serious
oh [__] dude [__]
yeah uh let's see what else so we talked
about we didn't talk about Trump that's
in the title yeah
yeah yeah
it is oh boy oh here he is the guy yo he
did a big one this is the this is the
one
we've all been waiting for
eign
the grand jury just voted to indict
Donald Trump for his hush money payments
to Stormy Daniels this is big
[Music]
yeah it's uh towards the top of the show
oh it's not the same guy it's not the
same guy but it's a contender it's
really yeah number 13 in top of the show
thank you
let's take a look
oh yes
oh yes Lord yes
[Music]
now play the big news oh boy at the same
time
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah so Trump got indicted
um
basically
for what happened is uh he
he's a [__] idiot is what happened he
broke the law some dumb [__]
back when he was running for president
he paid off Stormy Daniels who he had an
affair with 120
000 I think or 60 or 30. no no no no 130
000 to not uh share the story with the
Press
she agreed
and to keep it quiet what they did is
they had Michael Cohen who went to jail
for this acts specific crime he Michael
Cohen Trump's attorney at the time paid
her the 130 000.
and then Trump reimbursed him from
campaign funds yes now this broke
several laws uh and an effort to cover
up the payment and so but it's important
to remember Michael Cohen went to jail
for that crime that he did for Donald
Trump
that's why he went to jail it wasn't the
Nike no that was the no that's the other
idiot Avenues
okay okay the goat got it and by the way
it's interesting so confused okay all
right there's all there's a lot of [__]
bags yes and so what's interesting is if
I think back to the conservatives a lot
of them were like oh Cohen he's just a
criminal in jail don't listen to him I
remember that I remember being confused
like if if his attorney is going to jail
for it why why aren't we talking about
the person who hired him to do it he's a
mobster he he did he's doing
racketeering he had someone else commit
the crime for him that's why Michael
Cohen did it not him yes right that was
the crime that's what Mobsters do and
then he still turned on him right Trump
oh well Michael Co they kind of turned
on each other I don't know the timeline
of it yeah thick as thieves for sure
Michael Cohen's still on a Donald Trump
hate uh a tour
but so Michael Cohen Trump paid back
Michael Cohen from campaign funds now
that you can't
you need to disclose what you spend your
campaign funds on so right off the bat
he misappropriated campaign funds which
in New York state
is a crime and then the other layer of
it
is he like falsified the business books
to hide it
which is also a crime and then when you
falsify the business books to conceal a
crime in New York City that specifically
is a felony okay
so they've been investigating this for a
long time
they've got a grand jury which is you
know a secret group of people who look
over the evidence and then decide
are we going to
um
indict him arrest him essentially and
try him
and in the grand jury the majority of
people voted it's all secret what
happens there but one thing we do know
is because he is getting indicted is
that the grand jury
the majority agreed that the evidence
was compelling enough that he should be
indicted
so that's what happened but what's
interesting is that in the grand jury
there was over two dozen specific
charges
we don't know what they are
as of going live today let me see if any
more information again everything
happens in Grand Jury is very uh secret
CNN reported 34 charges whoa we don't
know what they are no do we know what
kind of punishment is facing I think
it's like
um a couple years in jail
okay that's what Michael Cohen did I
mean how long was Michael Cohen in jail
for
I think he was sentenced to two years or
something and he got out after like six
months or something like that correct me
if I'm wrong because I don't remember
but when Cohen went against the family a
lot of the conservative media discounted
him as a criminal he's in jail
so that right so I don't think they had
a problem with Michael Cohen going to
jail for that
but now that Trump gets arrested for it
it's an outrage I'm sure they have some
kind of talking point about it convince
themselves I don't know
they have some talking points already
yeah they figure it out but um so I mean
he committed a crime
there's no question about it
it's far from the most serious crime
he's committed to be honest but it is
yeah but you say there's no question
about it
not until he's convicted so we don't we
don't know a hundred you can't say that
I don't think that's what I meant to say
what did I say he 100 did the crime you
don't have to 100 do the crime to get
indicted there just needs to be enough
evidence
like you said earlier they decided
there's enough compelling evidence the
grand jury the grand jury is not proving
he's guilty they just need to agree by a
majority that they think that there's a
compelling case to be tried yeah so
that's why he was indicted what I was
it's not close to his most serious crime
yeah but uh the evidence okay so there's
a compelling uh case there but yeah so
he you know
he's accused of committing a crime and
like what the [__] do we what the [__]
do people want I mean what he's accused
of I meant is 100 a crime
and in fact his attorney went to jail
for doing that for him so you know I
personally to me in a democracy people
are all
nobody's Above the Law we hear that said
all the time
but do we mean it
um
you know I don't know I I mean clearly
they don't
it's the first time ever a president has
been uh sitting or previous has ever
been charged with the crime
yeah I think that's crazy about America
I don't know like in I'm in Israel I've
definitely seen Prime Ministers go to
jail oh yeah they go down all the time
but that's that's a good thing because
they're still accountable like everybody
else
and in America there's this precedent
that at least you can't charge a sitting
president in fact so Trump didn't even
get charged when he was president
because they couldn't they just couldn't
charge them with the crime because he
was President it's weird but
um it's according to this he could uh
face a maximum of four years in prison
so of course the right wing uh
uh media sphere is uh melting down
I mean I don't know what do you think I
mean it's like
people say is it worth it is it a
mistake I don't really even think it
goes that far I mean you do a crime you
get challenged for it I mean what's the
deal I don't see what's a mistake about
it uh it's actually something that would
only happen in stalinist Russia that's a
communist state
um that's what they say the The Eagle
Has Fallen
um this country is over
um
it's been terminated to a permanent end
of course what they're saying is that
optically
the political opposition group is being
arrested
and that is like uh you know that's
something that only happens in banana
republics the ones that you know we set
up and Fund in uh Central America but
yeah it's funny because it's for sure we
can all see if this is not trumped up
imaginary charges this has been like
stewing for years and years and years
like everybody knows no no no this
wasn't just and I don't think 100 out of
thin air and the D.A would not take this
to a grand jury if they weren't feeling
pretty calm I mean I I don't know
anything about this particular D.A other
than he's back by George Soros and the
Jews and the Jews oh no uh but other
than that uh yeah I don't know like
at some point Trump was uh implying that
all of this was extortion like not even
like really denying that the money was
given to her but that it was all
blackmail and it was all [__] in
order to try and torpedo his campaign he
had to cough up a bunch of money to just
avoid that so
I'm sure that's going to come up in
court right
which means the Crux of it or at least
of some of the charges will be did he
actually have this affair did he [__]
Stormy Daniels or not and so does it
matter he still hid the hush money
but if it's done under duress uh of
being blackmailed because like blackmail
made into the crime well yeah I mean
obviously they're not believing that and
they're charging anyways I'm just
curious if they like have him a hundred
percent on the affair which would be
pretty funny
that would be again that would be good
uh but anyway here's some of the right
wing uh reactions too
for this here we go Trump is a criminal
Democrats are branding Trump as a
criminal it's legally pathetic it's
clickbait it is an unbelievable abuse of
Justice pure balderdale whoa
this guy look at this literal thumb do
you think he's a cop I'm saying Wilson
why does he have fingerprints on his
face he said he looks like a dummy
you're right
it's in my eyes looking a little
emotional I feel the same way if there's
a mug shot of Donald Trump it'll be in
dorm rooms and on t-shirts he is okay
and OG he was convicted that's not gonna
stop him Donald Trump could run in park
on saying I'm going to Pardon myself and
go after uh the Deep State it's not open
for a debate that we live in a police
state it's like Stalin's purges we're
Crossing the Rubicon here this is a
political Rubicon that has been crossed
they have crossed the Rubicon
by the way the and the irony is just so
insanely [__] pathetic these are
people who literally ran on the premise
of locking up his political opponent
yeah was literally screamed lock her up
all day every day at every rally this
whole [__] like one of his main points
was to lock up his political opponent
hell yeah it's it's like shut the [__]
up basically it's one party hunting
another it almost feels like they're
pushing the population to react it is
more on conservatism and Maga they want
you to strike out people better be
careful and that's all I'll say about
that Democrats what are you gonna do
about your little [__] are you gonna
puncture my tires and try to [__] my
wife isn't that what he did watch your
back uh he let the air out of the tires
of I believe an intern you hear about it
is the junior producer or something so
this guy was trying to pick up a a girl
really so it's a way to get create an
end for him he let the air out of her
tires oh my God
while he was married by the way he was
married yeah by the way love it our
branding Trump is a criminal it's
legally pathetic it's clickbait it is an
unbelievable abuse of Justice pure
balderner
well
I'm can't go over boulder dash
personally
yeah so well what's interesting is he's
going to be tried in Manhattan which is
I don't know if they're gonna be able to
find a jury that's not going to convince
his ass of anything Manhattan they
[__] ate him there as much as
anywhere oh there's Mega people in New
York too yeah Manhattan maybe Joey uh
will find his way onto the jury that's
true salad head no he has a lot of um
because I again
I watched the housewives New York oh
okay right and you know a thing or two
about New York a lot of them voted for
him and they talked they like they
didn't want to talk about it but they
were backed into a corner to talk about
it
and
um they're like yeah I met him you know
they they all Mingle
the the rich people of New York
that's true so you're right yeah
um let's see uh oh he posted a truth
social guys
he said these Thugs and radical left
monsters
I've just
indicated that the 45th president United
States of America and the leader he was
trying to say indict he spelled it wrong
is that I got cut up but I was like
that's insane diet yeah
indicated
and the leading Republican candidate by
far by far by far people for the 2024
nomination for president this is an
attack on our country the likes of which
we have never seen before it is likewise
and continuing attack on our once free
and fair elections so fair
the fairest and freest
uh the U.S is now a third world nation a
nation in serious decline so sad so sad
it's very sad sad so sad really sad okay
here on Fox News when the news broke
they were
audible gasps broke out about uh there
you can hear listening
pretty great just gotten word former
president Donald Trump has been indicted
here we have just gotten word former
I think they said [__] I think
somebody's saying [__] [__]
wait there's another just past that
there's another little detail here uh we
have just gotten worse
for his alleged hush also there was some
Fox News people that were crying I
believe
there's one man above all who earned
this moment of course that is our boy uh
this [__] idiot Jeff teedrick
Give It Up
I give it up
he's kind of lost now yeah but but you
know what
hearing this he got a million followers
for that huh
the legend Miss Jeff it's our boy Jeff
teedrick and there's no other picture of
him only the super weird ass [__]
photo because I was like what does he
really look like and this is it this is
all you got
[Music]
he said uh hahaha
oops I mean how terrible for Donald
Trump oh [__] got him that's a that's
really not funny or interesting or
clever I mean but who am I to uh Jeff is
our boy knows what he's doing he's the
best he's got a million followers he's
built the whole career off yeah
epic burns like that one he represents
the best of us and uh well we salute you
Jeff welcome back
um there is let's see
Junior uh is out doing press tours DJ TJ
he has a really articulate leftovers
statement on his podcast triggered
it's a great name she has a podcast
named triggered I'm like written out for
a minute it's great to just have
triggered plastered on your screen as
we're literally crying
you're you're owning me so hard right
now yeah it's true
proven even more right than I would have
ever imagined because apparently you
know Soros to back Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg is actually
indicting my father so do you think you
went a little white on the team I was
just staring at his teeth what the [__]
man they're so white I wasn't even
listening to what he was saying look at
this [__] I can see Trump uh junior
waiting your teeth it's disgusting right
he goes all super white anything to
please you
look at this man's [__] teeth dude
it's like porcelain from a toilet bowl
let me put some [__] streaks on that boy
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
is actually indicting my father so let's
be clear folks this is
like communist level [__] this is stuff
that would make
oh my God how does anybody listen to
this guy pull pot
this is worse than the Cambodian
genocide what's happening Stalin would
have been oh my
I can't believe this but very eloquently
this is like communist level [__] man
I'm the smart guy I can see why uh
why uh
he's set to inherit nothing yeah
um
let's see
his even dumber son yeah out of state
dude this guy I don't even know why they
even let this guy like on TV
this dude is dumb as a [__] this
guy makes oh Eric he makes Junior look
like a damn NASA scientist
pick this up conversation of politics
and of the justice system we've seen it
with the FBI we've seen it with the doj
we've seen it time and time again at
some point the guy deserves a pass give
him a pass Hillary Clinton's out of pass
Hillary Clinton of course this is him on
Hannity yeah that's a pass which is the
film of a pass the second most popular
show probably in in cable television
News Hannity uh I think he's falling off
quite a bit but uh yeah I don't know
listen where is that now boys will be
boys what can I say Kennedy's got like a
whistle going on the way he talks it's
getting a big ass head like Jay Leno
just keeps growing it's just [__]
like
yeah adaptation of politics and of the
justice system we've seen it with the
FBI we've seen it with the doj we've
seen it time and time again at some
point the guy deserves a pass yeah well
Hillary Clinton got a pass Hillary
Clinton of course 33
000 deleted emails no dude you guys
gotta wait hold on but that's the thing
like he's saying that his dad did it
like give him a pass yeah basically yeah
just give him a pass they're like
Hillary Clinton got a pass with her
deleted emails so they're saying that's
a crime so my dad gets to do some crimes
get out of jail free card yeah
but if it was up to them they would
throw her in jail yes and kill her but
because she didn't get jail then he
should get a pass
you got to think about like
so Donald Trump has two [__] up
incompetent boys
and so he becomes president and now we
got to listen to these [__] talk on
television like they know anything about
anything like they're nobodies they're
like College Dropout [__] ups losers
[__] cokeheads they've made nothing
with themselves and now their dad became
president they're going to put on suits
and make us listen to them on Fox News
like they have an opinion worth
listening to it's crazy
give him a pass he says
prosecute or whatever prosecute James
Coleman he infamously said uh then of
course the dirty dossier that was used
by the FBI in the 2016 election uh
unverifiable because
uh but yet they signed five four fisa
warrants three by Jim Comey himself shut
up yeah whatever it was mostly just for
the past [__]
uh Lindsay oh no Lindsey Graham I think
he was crying wasn't he yeah well it's
hard to feel hard to tell but it looked
like he might be he's on the verge of
crying yeah
how do you do it you take it
he's crying but I don't think he
actually gives a [__] so do you think he
like just like rubbed his eyes really
hard or to make it look like he's upset
and if he's getting lost in the sauce I
think he cares
he's being emotional he's way more
cynical than that come on is Lindsey
Graham could this be Stone
oh it was unexpected he's like oh [__] I
gotta go on air now so how do you do it
you take a well if you got a pile of
crap and he'd chop it up 34 times it's
still a pile of crap it's duplicious
charging they're trying to disappear the
guy they're trying to take cases that
nobody else would take and resurrect
them this is literally legal Voodoo
literally literally
bro it's magic
what is this language you're talking
legal Voodoo I don't like the sound of
that
I know Voodoo ain't right DeSantis
tweeted out let's see what he had to say
of course they're becoming bitter
enemies uh as they are about to face off
he's got his back this time though the
weaponization of the legal system to
advance a political agenda turns the
rule of law on its head
I'm wondering
um how what he thinks about making it
illegal to discuss gay people gayness in
school
if that's weaponizing
the legal system for a political agenda
it's on American
thesaurus backed dude they're so crazy
for that the source back Manhattan
district attorney has consistently bent
the law to downgrade felonies and to
excuse criminal misconduct yet now he is
stretching the law to Target a political
opponent
Florida will not assist in an
extradition request given amazing I
don't think they need Florida's
assistance to yeah I don't think so
you know amazing given the questionable
circumstance of the issue with the
sorrow you've said that already sore
respect Manhattan prosecutor in his
political agenda did he mention any
Sorrows backed
is that even true
from what I understand uh no no the
short answer is no that's awesome I mean
he Soros donated like all billionaires
due to a bunch of packs and one of them
don't donated some money to another
organization then that money was donated
to his campaign and it was like 50. it
was like fifteen hundred dollars sounds
like Voodoo to me that's voodoo
uh I don't like voodoo
onto my ex-girlfriend did a little
voodoo on me I felt that boy took my dog
Effigy put a pen in it felt that right
there in my arm little Voodoo time I
didn't like that one bit
now we got them Democrats doing legal
food though
team right
witchcraft in the white house it's
getting late Rhonda brother you you mind
your p's and thought your cues little
lady
all right
well that was good times man I love that
oh I forgot to say when I was in the
bathroom somebody from YouTube called me
really by the way my rep I told him if
you're reaching out or texting me can
you just tell me before lead with I'm
not in trouble because I [__] myself
every time you call me because usually
whenever we get in trouble he calls me
and tells me right
so he texts me he says you're not in
trouble
my phone I said thank God so I call him
he says we were watching your podcast
and we saw you talking to um
uh fish and Garrett yes and we would
love to help him out oh my god oh well
so they got someone there a partner
manager that they want to get in touch
with Garrett and they're going to help
get all that content let's [__] go
right now yeah it's awesome so that was
great that was really cool more
surprising is anybody at YouTube
watching the show yeah that that
surprised me that was what yeah he said
someone was watching the show and they
wanted to reach out to Garrett I thought
that was cool too yeah I don't know if
we should be flattered or worried about
that that's a good question frankly
so I'm waiting for an email from them
and then I guess I'll write an intro to
Garrett
um
but that's exciting yeah very cool I was
saying I loved him he's so great
um that's about it that's it
that's about it let's ask chat gbt one
more thing wrap it up let's get on out
of here if my farts smell like beef
jerky should I be worried I don't know
let's see it tastes like beef jerky I'm
not a doctor
we have farts smell like beef jerky it's
not necessarily a cause for concern
if it's if the smell is consistent and
accompanied by other symptoms like
abdominal pain right oh yeah duh I mean
come on this thing this doctor sucks
well he liked that he says no
no you're cool
what if my farts
farted smell like um rotten I don't know
what what's like a weird uh what if my
farts smell uh
really good to me
be worried
if your first felt good to you it's not
necessarily a cause for concern either
the perception of smell is of course
subjective
fascinating
what if I love smelling people's farts
all right
check us out thank you see you all next
week Monday